SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL THE- ALLEN LEADERSHIP
ARCHULETA THE ATKINS. DATE WELL.
FOR JUST. BRADFORD BY ADAM
CHIANG DALLY. DOG TERRASSE SO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HELLO. HUESO TADO.
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL MONNING MORE
LOCK MORALE. NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER
STERN I'M BURKE THE WHITE HOUSE
SKI WIENER WELL. MY NAME IS
MARK YEAH YEAH A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT THE MEMBERS IN
OUR GUESTS BE THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WHO
WILL BE LEADING PRESS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR MONEY AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING IS WOULD
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY STATE
HILL. PRESIDENT GRACIOUS AND
LOVING GOD AS AFRICAN AMERICANS
CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH TOMORROW
WE GIVE THANKS FOR THEIR HOPE
THEIR PERSEVERANCE AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF SOCIETY MAY WE
REMEMBER AND ACT ON THE WORDS
OF CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER
PROFESSOR IN THEOLOGIAN HOWARD
WASHINGTON THURMAN. IN HIS
WORDS. LOOK WELL TO THE GROWING
EDGE. ALL AROUND THIS WORLD HER
DYING IN NEW WORLDS ARE BEING
BORN. THE FRUIT RIPENS ON THE
TREE. THE ROOTS ARE SILENTLY AT
WORK IN THE DARKNESS OF THE
YEARS. AGAINST A TIME WHEN
THERE SHALL BE NEW LEAVES FRESH
BLOSSOMS GREEN FRUIT SUCH IS
THE GROWING EDGE. THIS IS THE
BASIS OF HOPE IN MOMENTS OF
DESPAIR. THE INCENTIVE TO
CARRYING ON WHEN TIMES ARE OUT
OF JOINT AND PEOPLE HAVE LOST
THEIR REASON. THE SOURCE OF
CONFIDENCE WHEN WORLDS CRASH IN
DREAMS WHITEN TASH. LOOK WELL
TO THE GROWING EDGE. LOVING GOD
MAY WE NOT CLOSE OUR EYES TO
THE GROWING EDGES IN OUR OWN
WAY OF LIFE. ME WE ACTIVELY
ENGAGE IN DISMANTLING THE
SYSTEMS OF INJUSTICE THE
PREVENT ALL OF THIS FROM LIVING
IN TRUCE. AND INTEGRITY. AMEN.
WHERE IS OUR ALLY I. HI UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. THIS CALL.
NOW IT MEMBERS WILL MOVE THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. PORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOVING
ON NOW MEMBERS TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO RULE TWENTY NINE
TEN THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE FOR
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE I AM
FIVE SB THREE FIFTY ITEM SEVEN
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNAL
FOR JUNE FIFTEENTH THROUGH THE
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION DO PASS WILL
BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING
UPON BEING REPORTED IN ORDER TO
THIRD READING. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
TODAY AND TOMORROW WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THE
SECOND READING. AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED IN RETURN TO SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED ON FRIDAY
SATURDAY AN SUNDAY BUT AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED AND
PUBLISHED. MR MAJORITY LEADER.
BUT OF THAT. OKAY. YEAH WE WILL
MAKE. BUT. TO WHAT THE- OKAY.
FOR THE- ALL RIGHT MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION THE
DAILY FILE WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
SENATE THIRD READING. AND THAT
WILL START WITH ITEM NINE.
CLARK PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
EIGHT OR NIE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACT RELATING TO THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY. SIX SENATOR A-
SENATOR I WOULD BE CHILL. DID
NOT HAVE MY COPY IS MORE
INTERESTING BROTHER WE GET AN
OLD UNDERSTAND. IF IT HADN'T
SAID MITCHELL UP THERE MYSELF I
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO HELP YOU A
GOOD MORNING MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS THE NEXT FORTY MEN
MEASURES SB EIGHT OR NINE
THROUGH SB EIGHT FOUR EIGHT.
ARE BEING SENT OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR PURPOSES OF
BECOMING BUDGET TRAILER
VEHICLES AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS THE ASSEMBLY CENTER
SYMBOL AND A SIMILAR NUMBER
BILLS OVER TO OUR HOUSE THIS
PAST MONDAY. DUE TO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE WERE
UNABLE TO COMPLETE THIS TRAILER
BILL SWAP EARLIER IN THE YEAR
HOWEVER WITH CONTINUED ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS AND THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT WE WILL HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL FOLLOW AT WORK TO
DO OVER THE SUMMER. THIS ACTION
IS STILL NECESSARY TO ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
SENATE BUDGET TO THE STATE
BUDGET THIS ACTION IS A
PROCEDURAL STEP. TO ENSURE WE
ARE ABLE TO MEET OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET
RESPONSIBILITIES. I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. THE CENTER NIELSEN.
THIS PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE I RISE ASKING A NO VOTE.
I MAKE THE SAME COMPLAINTS EACH
YEAR. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
YEARS IT IS THE NEAR DECADE NOW
WE HAVE HAD A FULL REFER HELLO
THE LIBERATION OF TRAILER BILLS.
I THINK THIS IS ABOUT THE
HIGHEST EVER FORTY. TAYLOR
BILLS. TAYLOR BILLS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BUDGET WELL WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE A BUDGET RIGHT NOW OF
TECHNICALLY I GUESS AN ARGUABLE
I'D SAY THERE WAS ONE BUT IT'S
GOING TO TRAIL ON FOR. AND
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS HOLE
LEGISLATIVE PROGRAMS. ARE NOW
RUN INTO TRAILER BILLS MAJOR
POLICY. DECISIONS ARE EMBODIED
IN TRAILER BILLS. THAT IS NOT
AN OPEN TRANSPARENT LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE JUST GOT TOO MANY OF
THEM WERE CHOKING ON A AND
DOING A DISSERVICE HI VIRGIN
MOBILE. AT THE WHICH STEP
DELAYED IF YOU WANT TO CARRY ON
AND SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE AND
OTHERS WE DON'T NEED TO GO
THROUGH EVERYONE. GRAY AND
THANK YOU SIR. THE OTHER MIKES
UP. SIX NINE CLERK CALLED THE
ROLL. ALL I'M SORRY SIR
MITCHELL LIKE TO CLOSE YES IF
YOU DON'T MIND PLEASE I DO DO
NOT MIND AT ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WOULD JUST SAY
COLLEAGUES- THIS BODY DID
ACTUALLY TAKE A VOTE ON MONDAY
AND VOTE ON A- BUDGET. SECONDLY
ARE WE MAY NOT USE ALL FORTY
THIS CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY IF
INDEED. FORTY TRAILER BILLS ARE
NEEDED I APPRECIATE THAT THE
NUMBER MAY FEEL OVERWHELMING TO
SOME BUT- THIS IS IN A
SITUATION TO WHERE WE WILL FIND
ISSUES TO PUT IN THE BILL JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE A VEHICLE- THIS
IS TO ALLOW US. IF THEY ARE
NEEDED- AND WE HAVE DONE THE
ANSWER WITH THE POINT IS TO DO
THE TRANSFER WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AS WE DO EVERY YEAR. AND SO
AGAIN ON THE TEACHER ACTION ON
US FOR NOT OUT. THE CENTER
MITCHELL THAT THIRD CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI I ARCHULETA OR
AYE ATKINS I BATES NO BELL. I
FOR JUST. NO BRADFORD I CUT BY
ADAM. I CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD
I THE RICIN. I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG I HILL HI HUESO- I-
TADO. HI JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING. I MORE
LONG. NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
AMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER. I WILK NO. I TWENTY
NINE THOSE ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS OF FALLING
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MEMBERS FIND BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ A THIRD TIME SENATE
DEALS EIGHT TEN TO EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT AND THAT WOULD BE FILE
ITEMS TEN THROUGH FORTY EIGHT
IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL OF ICE
TWENTY NINE NEWS I HAVE BEEN
WILL BE APPLIED TO THE SENATE
BILLS EIGHT TEN THROUGH EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT. SEEING NO
OBJECTION BILLS ARE PASSED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN.
EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES THE MAJORITY LEADER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT THERE'S A
RESOLUTION OF THE DEATHS
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SPEND
OUR JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE AND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TEND T BE HEARD AND
REPORTED BY COMMITTEE. I ASK
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. GEORGE
LEADER ASPIRIN ON A VOTE THANK
YOU SIR. SENATE SENATOR GROW.
WELL ON THE I'M SORRY CENTER
GROUP THERE IS NO DEBATE ON
THIS. MY MISTAKE I APOLOGIZE.
SO SECRETARY READ RESOLUTION
AND WE'LL GO TO VOTE. RESOLVED
THAT JOINT RULES OF SIXTY ONE
AND SIXTY TO BE DISPENSED WITH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO WELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE ITEM. BY CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD I TORONTO HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI LESTER. I
HI- TADO I JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO
MITCHELL I MONEY HI MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER I WILL
YEAH NO. CLARK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS. NO.
CHIANG NO. PRICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN JOINT RULE SIXTY
ONE IS SUSPENDED. AND SIXTY TWO
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING READING ITEM SIXTY NINE
CLARK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AN ACT RELATING TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND I STAND
HERE TODAY HONORED TO PRESENT
AB. FOURTEEN SIXTY. HI ETHNIC
STUDIES BILL OUR REQUIREMENT
FOR CAL STATE UNIVERSITY.
VETERANS PART OF THE FIGHT
AGAINST RACISM REQUIRES US TO
INCREASE OUR UNDERSTANDING. ONE
ANOTHER IN OUR HISTORY. WE NEED
STUDENTS TO KNOW. NOT ONLY OF
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF WHITE
AMERICANS BUT OF BLACK LATINO
ASIAN AND NATIVE AMERICANS AND
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS.
COUNTRY. FOR FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
WE HAVE SANITIZED AND
WHITEWASHED HISTORY FULL OF
LIES WELL AND THE NILES. NOT SO
TIME FOR THE TRUTH BECAUSE THAT
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW THE TRUTH
WILL SET YOU FREE. JAMES
BALDWIN ONCE STATED GREAT THE
GREAT FORCE OF THREE COUNTS
FROM THAT WE CARRY IT WITHIN
OPS. OUR UNCONSCIOUSLY
CONTROLLED ARE UNCONSCIOUSLY
CONTROLLED IN MANY WAYS AND OUR
HISTORY IS LERI PRESIDENT AND
ALL THAT WE DO. FOR STUDENTS DO
NOT UNDERSTAND THAT FOR FOUR
HUNDRED YEAR HISTORY A WHITE
SUPREMACY AND SUBJUGATION IN
THIS COUNTRY HOW CAN THEY
UNDERSTAND THE MOMENT OF NOW.
THE LEGACY OF THAT HISTORY IS
STILL ALL AROUND US TODAY. IT'S
VISIBLE IN WHO CAN BUY A HOUSE
AND WERE YOU CAN BUY A HOUSE
DUE TO RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
AND RED LINING THERE ONCE
EXISTED. IT'S VISIBLE AND WHOSE
INCARCERATED. AND WHO'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE LEGACY OF
SLAVERY IN THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT THE WAR ON DRUGS. AND
OTHER INSTITUTIONAL BIASES.
IT'S VISIBLE IN WHICH FAMILIES
HAVE INTER GENERATIONAL WEALTH
AND WHICH ONES HAVE ONE TENTH
OF THAT WEALTH ON AVERAGE TO
WHITE PRIVILEGE. IT'S VISIBLE
ON WHO CAN DRAW FREELY AND WHO
GETS MURDERED WHILE ACT.
EXERCISING ON THE WRONG STREET
LIKE AHMAD ARBOR. IS VISIBLE IN
WALL STREET WOULD FRAUD STURGE
LIKE. VERY MADE OFF MICHAEL
MILKEN IVAN BOESKY IN EVEN
OCCUPIERS OF THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR FINANCIAL CRIMES UNLIKE
GEORGE FLOYD. WHO DIED FOR
MAYBE PASSING A FAKE TWENTY
DOLLAR BILL. EVERY YEAR BLACK
CAUCUS DOES A RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATING THE ANNIVERSARY
OF JUNE TENTH THE ENDING OF
SLAVERY. JUNE TENTH IS TOMORROW.
WE DON'T DO THE RESOLUTION JUST
BECAUSE- IT'S THE ANNIVERSARY
REDO IT BECAUSE TOO FEW PEOPLE
KNOW THE HISTORY OF JUNETEENTH.
EVERY YEAR MEMBERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE SURE THEIR
IGNORANCE OF JUNE TENTH TEEN
BUT REALLY THEY'RE SURE THAT IT
NEEDS OF THIS COUNTRY AND OUR
HISTORY. TOO FEW PEOPLE MOSTLY
ROOM TO WORK FOR YEARS AND IN
MANY WAYS STILL AND DOOR NOW.
EN AFTER THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION WE HAD. BY LAW
SUCH AS PLESSY VERSUS FERGUSON
JIM CROW. LEGALIZE LUNCHEON AND
MANY OTHER ACTS OF DOMESTIC
WHITE SUPREMACIST TERRORISM IN
THIS COUNTRY AND I THINK
STUDIES REQUIREMENT WILL HELP
FIX THAT IGNORANCE FIFTY YEARS
AGO THE CAL STATE SYSTEM BECAME
THE BIRTHPLACE OF MODERN ETHNIC
STUDIES BUT I WOULD CHALLENGE
ANY CAL STATE GRADUATE ANY. US
YOU YOU SEE GRADUATING YOU SEE
LA OR U. S. C. OR STANFORD
HARVARD YOUR BEST MINDS I WILL
CHALLENGE YOU AGAINST A HIS
DEBATE WITH ANYONE WANT TO H.
B. C. USE THAT WOULD CLEAN YOUR
CLOCK BECAUSE IT H. B. C. USE
STATE CAME HISTORY. SANITIZED
HISTORY. THE BILL CODIFIES THE
NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE CHANCES OFFICE TASK FORCE
REPORT WHICH IS TO INCLUDE
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES THE
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. NOW I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME WHO
HAVE RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE DICTATING CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CURRICULUM BUT IS
PRICE MANY OF THE SAME FOLKS
ALL POLLS REMOVING OF RACES
HEROES IN THIS COUNTRY AS WELL
AND- CHANGING THE NAMES OF
NAVAL AND ARMY BASES AS WELL.
BUT CONTINUED IGNORANCE IS EVEN
MORE COSTLY AND THIS
REQUIREMENT IS JUSTIFIED IN
OVERDUE THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT
OF NOT ONLY A BLOCK CAUCUS
DATING CAUCUS LATINO CAUCUS.
AND IT'S ALSO SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PROPERTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AMONG
MANY MANY MORE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR BRADFORD MOVING ON TO
DEBATE. CENTER BARGES. THANK
YOU A MISS PRESIDENT. I LIKE TO
THINK THAT I A- RECEIVED A VERY
WELL ROUNDED. LIBERAL ARTS
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION SETTING
LITERATURE PHILOSOPHY NATURALLY
I HAD A NUMBER OF COURSES THAT
DEALT WITH ETHNIC COMPONENTS
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT HELPED
ME QUITE A BIT IN BETTER
APPRECIATING- MY ROLE IN THIS
WORLD AND IN THOSE A PART OF IT.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE
RIGHT HERE IS THAT WE ARE
CREATING- IN A POSITION. THAT
PERHAPS ONE OF THE WORST TIMES
THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY IMAGINE
FINANCIALLY. NOW BASED ON THE
REPORT THAT I READ HERE IS THAT
THIS WOULD. RUN ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. WE ARE REELING
FROM. THE VIRUS PANDEMIC WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE FULL
BREADTH AND COST OF HAVING TO
CONVERT TO DISTANCE LEARNING.
WE HAVE ADJUNCT FACULTY THROUGH
OUR C. ISSUE SYSTEM THERE ARE
LIKELY GOING TO BE PUT ON ICE
IN WE ARE ON CLEAR THE RATE OF
ATTRITION. AND THOSE STUDENTS
WHO MAY NOT COME BACK GIVEN
WHAT THE NEW BRICK AND MORTAR
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES LIKE.
ALL THIS USE AN EXAMPLE ON MY
HAPPENED AND I HAD THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING FRESNO STATE ONE
OF THE C. ISSUES. THE SHORTFALL
RIGHT NOW IS ALREADY THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT WAS A
WHILE BACK. YOU ADD THAT TO THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY STUDENTS WILL BE COMING
BACK WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
SPORTS PROGRAM AND WHAT IMPACT
THAT MIGHT HAVE ON FOUNDATION
FUNDING IN OTHER RELATED TO-
FUNDRAISING EFFORTS IN SHORT.
WE ARE CREATING A SITUATION.
THAT IS I THINK IT IT'S HARD
BASED ON EDUCATION IN COULD BE
GOOD FOR THE OVERALL ACADEMIC
AND PERSONAL DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
STUDENTS BUT WE'RE CHOOSING THE
ABSOLUTE WORST TIME TO CREATE.
A IN A POSITION LIKE THIS IT'S
ALMOST AS IF THIS WOULD BE
BETTER SUITED IT THIS COULD
COME BACK IT'LL AT A LATER DATE
AND BE ON- DEBATED ON ON THE
MERITS BUT IS AS OF RIGHT NOW
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THOSE THAT REPRESENTS THE
ISSUES OR THOSE THAT HAVE A
LARGE CONSTITUENCY OF- ALUMNI
ASK YOURSELF WHAT IS THIS GOING
TO DO TO THE SCHOOL BASED ON
COSTS BECAUSE- OUR- THE WAY
THAT IT'S LIMITED RIGHT NOW IN
ETHNIC STUDIES IT SHOULD LIKELY
ALSO BE BROADENED TO A NUMBER
OF OTHER. COMPONENTS WHETHER IT
BE RELIGIOUS STUDIES WHETHER BE
SOCIAL STUDIES OR VARIOUS OTHER
INTERPOLATE YOUR CALL RELEVANT
TOPICS. BUT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE FACULTY WHO ARE
APPROPRIATELY SCHOOLED IN
CREDENTIALS TO MAKE THEIR WAY
INTO THE SYSTEM TO PROVIDE THIS
REQUIRED COURSE. THAT
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS IN IF YOU
DON'T. THE SCHOOLS GOING TO
HAVE TO INCORPORATE THAT JONES
AT A RATE THEY CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD NOW. SO FROM A PURELY
FISCAL STANDPOINT. COLLEAGUES I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK ALLOW
THIS MATTER TO BE BACK AYE IT
HAS MERITS WE ENHANCE OUR
ETHICS CITIES COMPONENT AS WELL
AS OUR RELIGIOUS COMPONENT. THE
RIGHT NOW SEE ISSUES ARE
REELING. I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD ADD TO THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR A GORGEOUS
CENTER MONEY. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA
FOR FRAMING THE ISSUE. SO WHILE
pI WANT TO THANK DOCTOR WEBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS ISSUE.
SIMPLY UT MEMBERS ETHNIC
STUDIES SHOULD BE FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND FOR ALL OF SOCIETY.
IF NOT NOW WHEN. THE TIME IS
OVERDUE. THE TIME IS NOW I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
MONNING SENATOR GROW NOT YET
OKAY MOVE ON TO SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS. I WANT FIRST OF ALL
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO THE SOME
MEMBER ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM. SAN
DIEGO WHO AUTHORED THIS
LEGISLATION FOR BRING THIS FORD
AND CALLING FOR ETHNIC STAYS BE
REQUIREMENTS FOR GRADUATION I
CERTAINLY I FULLY AGREE HE-
WITH THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL. I
DO. SHARES I DO HAVE SOME
FRUSTRATION- BECAUSE- CSU MORE
THAN THREE YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
CAME UP WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE SHOULD BE THE CASE AND
THEN NEVER BROUGHT IT BEFORE
THE FACULTY SENATE FOR-
CONSIDERATION AND DEBATE. AND
FACT WHEN THE BILL CAME BEFORE
ARE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
I ASKED THE CSU ABOUT THIS. NOW
WHY IS THIS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE. THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST TIME A WHICH WE ARE.
IMPOSING A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT ON THE ISSUE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE POWER TO DO
SO. AND I THINK YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND. AND APPRECIATE WHAT
THE ARE BOTH THE AUTHOR AND-
THE FLOOR JOCKEY HAS SAID ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND- CERTAINLY I AGREE
THAT IT'S PAST DUE. AT C. S.
YOU HAVE ACT ON THAT IN FACT A
CHALLENGE TO SEE IF YOU TO SAVE
WELL WHY DON'T YOU TAKE CARE OF
THIS YOURSELF IF YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE
MANDATING GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. IS
PREFERABLE I SHOULD SAY THAT
THE CSU. TAKE CARE OF ITSELF.
AND IN FACT THEY ARE TAKING
SOME STEPS TO DO SO HOWEVER I
DO ALSO THINK THAT THIS IS A-
FOR MANY REASONS AS ARTICULATED
BY TO BY MY GOOD FRIENDS LOS
ANGELES THAT THIS IS PAST DUE
AND WE NEED TO BE SURE THIS
HAPPENS AND NOT. I GET IT THE
BILL WOULD IMPLEMENTED AS PAST
OF THE FOLLOWING YEAR- BUT- WE
DO NEED THIS. TO MOVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY. SO I WILL BE
VOTING FOR THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AT THIS BILL NOT DIE. ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE CSU
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY- HAVE THAT
THEY HAD OPPORTUNITY ACT AND-
THEY HAVE NOT DONE SO YET EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE NOW SUDDENLY
WITH. GREAT A SELLER. TRYING TO
GET THIS ISSUE. BUT I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT IN THE END. ODDS CSU-
MOVE WITH ALL DUE SPEED. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BEFORE. THIS
BILL EVEN REQUIRE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ADDRESS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT OUR- PROBLEM AND
EFFICIENCY ACTUALLY IN THE
EDUCATION. OF THE STUDENTS AT
SEA ISSUES SO I DO URGE TO
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AT THIS
BILL. CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND AGAIN WOULD URGE CSU ITSELF
TO. RAPIDLY ADDRESSES ISSUES
ALL THESE SPEED. WE SHOULD NOT
LET ANOTHER GRADUATING CLASS AS
USE YOU. ARE GRADUATE OUT.
HAVING BEEN EDUCATED. AND FULL
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
CENTER ALSO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES GARDENA. AND
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
DIEGO- FOR ALL THREE IN THIS
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE READS THAT
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE SEE IS DO THIS WITH THE
TO ACQUIRE THE KNOWLEDGE AND
THE SKILLS THAT WILL HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND. THE DIVERSITY AND
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE HISTORY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
SOCIETY THAT THEY LIVE IN IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY AS
RESPONSIBLE AND CONSTRUCTIVE
CITIZENS. COLLEAGUES I'VE SPENT
THE MAJORITY OF MY LIFE
FIGHTING AGAINST INJUSTICES.
THAT DETRIMENTALLY IMPACT
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE FIRST
TIME I LEARN ANYTHING ABOUT
MEXICAN HISTORY MEXICAN
AMERICAN HISTORY. BLACK HISTORY
BEYOND KNOWING THE NAME OF THE
GREAT MAN OF MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BUT UNDERSTANDING. BETTER YET
THE NONVIOLENT CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT FIRST TIME I LEARNED
ANYTHING ABOUT THE API
COMMUNITY IN THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF. LUPINO WORKERS IN THE FIELD
OR THE INTERNMENT CAMPS. WITH
WHEN AS A STUDENT WE FOUGHT FOR
THESE STUDIES. AT SAINT MARY'S
COLLEGE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
WE DON'T GET THOSE CLASSES
RIGHT AWAY SO WE FORMED A THIRD
WORLD CENTER. SO THAT WE AS
STUDENTS COULD SHARE WITH EACH
OTHER WHAT WE KNEW WHEN WE
STUDY TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE STRUGGLE
FOR EQUALITY AND JUSTICE FOR
MANY COMMUNITIES CONTINUED
TODAY. IT'S NOT JUST SOMETHING
IN THE PAST THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER MOVEMENT AGAINST THE
BRUTAL AND I'M JUST KILLINGS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND POLICE
BRUTALITY IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE REASON GOOD NEWS CONCERNING
MAJOR COURT DECISIONS UPHOLDING
PROTECTIONS AND FREEDOMS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES IN OUR LGBT
COMMUNITIES. AND YET THERE ARE
CHILDREN BEING LOCKED UP IN
CAGES BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN. OUR NATION DOES NOT
KNOW NOR UNDERSTAND THE ROLE
THAT RACE HAS PLAYED SINCE THE
FORMATION OF OUR GREAT NATION.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE AN OPEN AND
INCLUSIVE WAY OF THINKING
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY IN OUR
STATE IS BASED ON HUMAN
DIVERSITY. THAT IS HOW WE
DERIVE OUR STRENGTH. I THINK
THE CURRENT MOVEMENTS WILL
ULTIMATELY BE A KEY POINT IN
OUR HISTORY. AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
RACIAL INJUSTICES THAT CONTINUE
IN OUR SOCIETY. THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ENSURE THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THESE
CRITICAL SKILLS BECOME TOLERANT
COMPASSIONATE AND UNDERSTAND
THE DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE
THAT PEOPLE COME FROM. AND WHAT
TRAITS MAKE THEM WHO THEY ARE.
IS THE AUTHOR SO ELOQUENTLY
STATED IN HER STATEMENT. A
STATE CURRICULUM THAT REQUIRES
THAT MAKES THAT HE WILL HELP
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS LEARN
LESSONS FROM THE PAST TO BUILD
A BETTER FUTURE. MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES WE MUST TAKE ACTION
TO WORK TOWARDS MAKING THAT
BETTER FUTURE A REALITY NO MORE
EXCUSES FIVE DECADES LATER THE
TIME IS NOW. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU A. I'D LIKE HERE IN
THIS MICROPHONE IS AT THE CARE
OKAY IT'S KIND OF AN AWKWARD
SPOT HERE. MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF. THE UP. TO THE NEED
TO- TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THIS
BILL. I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THAN HAS
BEEN SHARED SO FAR ON THE
FLOOR. CERTAINLY IF NOT A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ABOUT
SUPPORT FOR ETHNIC STUDIES- WE
AS THAT. I THE COMMUNITY AS A
STATE IS A WORLD ARE BENEFITTED
FROM THE RICH UNDERSTANDING OF
THE DIVERSE CULTURES THAT
OCCUPY. OUR SPACE. THAT PEOPLE
THAT WE WORK WITH FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE WE BENEFIT FROM
THAT WITHOUT QUESTION. I KNOW
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR WHO HAS
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
TIRELESSLY. FOR DECADES. CAME
FROM MY UNIVERSITY SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY- AND I SERVED
AT AYE AYE BY FOUR YEARS DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO- A CATALOG. A RICH
IN CHOICES IN ETHNIC STUDIES I
TOOK A CLASS IN MEXICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES IN COLLEGE. AT
SAN DIEGO STATE IT TOOK A
COURSE IN WOMEN'S STUDIES. AT
SAN DIEGO STATE. THE CATALOG
AND THEN AND NOW IS FILLED
WITH. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN ABOUT. THE
BEAUTIFUL CULTURES AND HERITAGE
IS. OF OUR STATE OUR NATION AND
OUR AND OUR WORLD WE HAVE
DEPARTMENTS. AND MAJORS IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. SO IT'S NOT AS
IF THEY AND THE CATALOG IS
EMPTY. THE THAT WE SEE TODAY.
IN FACT THE CAMPUSES OF LISTEN
TO THIS. ISSUE AND THEY HAVE
WHAT'S CALLED A DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENT AT OUR UNIVERSITIES
TODAY DIVERSITY REQUIREMENT
WHAT IS IT IT MEANS THAT EACH
OF THE CAMPUSES IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THEIR FACULTY HAVE PUT A
REQUIREMENT ON STUDENTS. TO
TAKE A COURSE IN DIVERSITY. TO
GRADUATE FROM THEIR UNIVERSITY
TODAY. IN FACT THEY MENTION MY
ALMA MATER SAN DIEGO STATE
WHICH I'M PROUD OF. THEY DON'T
REQUIRE ONE COURSE AT SAN DIEGO
STATE THE REQUIRED TWO COURSES
ONE IN ETHNIC STUDIES. AND WHAT
A CULTURAL DIVERSITY OF COURSE
THAT UNIVERSITY IS HEADED BY
PRESIDENT TAYLOR TORI. IF
YOU'RE FROM. CHIEF GO CSU CHICO
HEADED BY PRESIDENT DEAL
HUTCHINSON THEY REQUIRE TWO
COURSES IN ETHNIC STUDIES TODAY.
WHAT IN U. S. DIVERSITY AND
WHAT AND GLOBAL CULTURES AT SAN
JOSE STATE HEADED BY MERRY BUT
PACEY AND- THEY HAVE A
REQUIREMENT. RIGHT NOW TODAY IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. IT'S TITLED
SOCIETY INEQUALITY IN THE U. S.
EVERYONE OF OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES TODAY. HAS A DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENTS. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO KNOW YOURS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY IN YOUR AREA PLEASE
STOP BY MY DESK GOING TO BE
HAPPY. TO SHARE WITH YOU. IT IS
TRUE. THAT THIS IDEA OF AN
ETHNIC STUDIES MANDATE. HAS
BEEN. IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT THE
CSU HAS LISTEN. THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
APPROVED A REQUIREMENT FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES. AND THAT
RECOMMENDATION WAS FORWARDED TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
TRUSTEES AND THROUGH THE COURSE
OF THIS YEAR THEY HAVE ENGAGED
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
STUDENTS WITH THE FACULTY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. ABOUT
FORMALISING NOT THE DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENT WHICH I'VE
EXPLAINED TO YOU WITH THE
CAMPUS IS. BETTER I AM A STATE
MANDATE. FOR ETHNIC STUDIES AT
THE UNIVERSITY AND THEY HAVE
COMPLETED THAT CONSULTATION
PROCESS. AND THAT PROPOSAL.
IT'S COMING BEFORE THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES A FEW WEEKS FROM TODAY.
LET ME MENTION WHAT THAT
PROPOSAL SAYS. IT WOULD REQUIRE
CSU UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS TO
THE COMPLETE ONE LOWER DIVISION
COURSES ETHNIC STUDIES AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE. AS A PART OF
THE CSU G. BREATH REQUIREMENTS.
VERSUS SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE BASED
ON A FOCUS ON THE INTERSECTION
OF RACE AND ETHNICITY. AND
DESCRIBE HOW RESISTED SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND LIBERATION AS
EXPERIENCED BY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND ARE RELEVANT TO
CURRENT ISSUES. THEY SHOULD
ALSO FOCUS ON HIERARCHY AND
OPPRESSION. THAT'S THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE FACULTY
WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THE
CURRICULUM AT OUR UNIVERSITIES.
THAT'S NOW BEFORE THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO BE HEARD- IN A
COUPLE WEEKS. NOW WHAT'S
NOTEWORTHY ABOUT. THIS PROPOSAL
BY THE UNIVERSITY BY THE
FACULTY. IS THAT IT DOES HAVE A
BROADER REQUIREMENT SIMPLY
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR FOUR
DIFFERENT CULTURES. IT MEANS
THAT COURSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
OFFERED AT THE UNIVERSITY
DEALING WITH. THIS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE DIVERSITY AND JUSTICE
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE ECONOMIC THE
POVERTY DISCRIMINATION
IMMIGRATION WOULD BE ELIGIBLE.
OR SIGN GENOCIDE WOULD NOW BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE THE TRUSTEES IN A
FEW WEEKS ARMENIAN CULTURE.
WOULDN'T BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
PROPOSAL ON THE FLOOR TODAY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE THE
TRUSTEES DISABILITY STUDIES
LGBT LITERATURE AND CULTURE
WOULDN'T BE INCLUDED UNDER WHAT
IS BEFORE US TODAY WOULD BE
INCLUDED UNDER THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE THE TRUSTEES ARAB
AMERICAN IDENTITY MUSLIM
FEMINISM. WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP
SO THE PROPOSAL THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HEAR AND I'M VERY
CONFIDENT THEY'RE GOING TO
APPROVE. HAS A BROADER BREAST.
TO INCORPORATE MANY OTHER
ASPECTS OF A WORLD THAT ARE
WORTHY OF STUDY. AND LEARNING.
IT WAS SPOKEN EARLIER. MAYBE
THE MOST TROUBLESOME ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL FOR US. IS THAT IT
TAKES WHAT IS TRADITIONALLY
BEEN. THE PURVIEW OF THE
FACULTY ARE UNIVERSITIES TO
DETERMINE CURRICULA IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP THAT THE TRUSTEES
AND TAKE IT OUT OF THE ROMAN
PUT IT IN THE POLITICAL REALM.
NOW AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME FOR
MANY MANY FROM MAYBE ON MY SIDE
OF THE AISLE THIS IS A PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW ARE IMPORTANT AND
ETHNIC STUDIES IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. BUT THINK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT THAT WOULD SET. WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ANY FIVE
YEARS AGO PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
WOULD HAVE BEEN ENACTED. WHO
LIVE THOUGHT PROPOSITION TWO OR
NINE WOULD HAVE BEEN ENACTED.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW TIME CHANGES THINGS
SO WE DON'T KNOW THE FUTURE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FROM NOW
WHO'S GOING TO LEAVE OUR STATE.
WHO'S GOING TO LEAD OUR SENATE.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF THE
GOVERNOR WAS NAME TRUNG. HOW
WOULD YOU FEEL IF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE OF TODAY.
REPRESENTING OUR STATE SENATE.
TOMORROW. DO YOU WANT THAT
LEADERSHIP. TELLING OUR
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT. SO THERE IS
ENORMOUS PRECEDENT THAT'S BEEN
SET BY THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
EVEN AS WORTHY. AN IMPORTANT AS
THIS ONE. ONE OF MY- MOST
ENJOYABLE PARTS OF BE A TRUSTEE.
WAS TO GO TO THE GRADUATION
CEREMONIES OF OUR UNIVERSITIES
EVERY YEAR. THE CSU GRADUATES
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS IT'S UNBELIEVABLY
GREAT. AND EVERY YEAR. I HEAR
THE SAME FACTS ABOUT THAT
STUDENT BODY. MORE THAN 60%
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO
GRADUATE. TALK ABOUT FLOORING
YOUR EMOTIONS WHEN YOU HEAR
THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY THAT'S%
BEEN GIVEN TO THEM THE CSU IS
BEEN VIEWED AS THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY AND IT IS. THAT'S
SOMETHING THE SPACE. IS THERE
ARE KIDS YOUR KIDS THERE LED BY
THE MOST DIVERSE LEADERSHIP
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP IN THE
WORLD. MORE PRESIDENT OF COLOR
AND WOMEN MORE THAN A MAJORITY
THE SAME WITH THE TRUSTEES
WHICH WE AFFIRM ON THIS FLOOR
THE LEADERSHP OF THE
UNIVERSITY IS OUR LEADERSHIP.
THERE ARE PEOPLE. AND THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO SHARE INPUT AND ADVICE FOR
THEM TO DO THEIR BEST WORK. BUT
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US AS GOOD.
HEARTED AT IS A IS IN A
RIGHTEOUS CAUSE. AS I A FOR. IS
NOT HOW WE SHOULD DO OUR BEST
WORK. MY FRIENDS. AND I KNOW
HOW UNCOMFORTABLE IT IS BECAUSE
AS WAS STATED EARLIER A VOTE
AGAINST THIS MEASURE IS NOT A
VOTE THAT SAYS YOU A FIRM
PREJUDICE AND- NOT A CHANCE IN
FACT YOU TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
OF THE DAY. AND YOU TALK ABOUT
THE WORK TO. READ OUR PUBLIC
PLACES. OF THOSE WHO HAVE
PRACTICED DISCRIMINATION. AN
INCREDIBLE WAYS. I HAVE BEEN A
LEADER THAT AFTER FIVE YEARS
AGO ON THIS FLOOR WE PASSED
LEGISLATION WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
IT WOULD TAKE THE NAMES OF
CONFEDERATE LEADERS OFF OUR
PUBLIC SPACES. SO WE HAVE AS A
SENATEEXERCISE APPROPRIATE
ACTIONS IN PLACES WHERE WE SEE
DISCRIMINATION AND PREJUDICE.
WHEN WE SPEAK HERE ON THE FLOOR
OUR VOICE OUR VOICE MATTERS.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE GOOD
CHOICES ABOUT WHEN WE SPEAK UP
RIGHTEOUSLY OF INJUSTICE.
BETTER VOICE THESE THE MATTER.
AND WE NEED TO PICK THE PLACES
IN WHICH THAT VOICE NEEDS TO BE
SPOKEN WITH CLARITY AND
FORCEFULNESS. AS OUR VOICE
MATTERS. AND SO I ASK YOU TODAY
IS THIS REALLY THAT SPACE. A
DIVERSE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WITH
GREAT LEADERSHIP. RESPONSIVE TO
THIS DAY OF WHAT THIS IS THE
GOALS OF THIS MEASURE OUR.
DIVERSITY OF CULTURE
UNDERSTANDING TOLERANCE. OF
COURSE IT IS. OF COURSE IT IS.
SO I WOULD SAY TO YOU MY
FRIENDS. WITH GREAT SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATION FOR THIS AUTHOR
FOR THIS. IMPORTANT COSTS OF
CREATING UNDERSTANDING AND
DIVERSITY. AND TOLERANCE OF ALL
PEOPLE OF OUR WORLD. THIS IS A
PLACE TO TAKE IT TO SIT OUT.
LET THE TRUSTEES TO THEIR WORK
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS LETTER
CAMPUS COMMUNITY DO THEIR BEST
WORK IN A COUPLE WEEKS I THINK
IT WILL MAKE ALL OF US PROUD.
AND IT WILL NOT SET THE
PRECEDENT THAT NONE OF US WOULD
SEE. IN SENATE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. OF INTERFERENCE. IN THE-
THERE IS A RE. THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE CONSTITUTION. IT MAKES AS
FRUSTRATED WE WANT THEM TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS BUT OUR OUR OUR
FOR THE FOLKS THAT. HAVE BEEN
AROUND THIS EARTH FOR A LONG
TIME NEW. WHERE THE POLITICS
SHOULD BE AND ONE OF THOSE
PLACES IT IN THE ACADEMY WE
HAVE PLENTY OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN OUR SYSTEM. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SIT OUT THIS VOTE. THE
YOU SIR GLAZER SENT ARE STILL.
THANK YOU FOR PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO THANK CENTER BRAD
REPRESENTING THIS. BILL TO US
IT IS SO IMPORTANT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS THE KEY
TO THE FUTURE OUR HISTORY AS WE
NOW SEE IT. IS TAINTED THERE'S
NO DOUBT THAT'S WHY THE STATUES
ARE COMING DOWN ALL OVER
AMERICA BECAUSE OUR HISTORY IS
TAINTED AND IF WE DON'T LOOK AT
OUR HISTORY WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO WITH OUR FUTURE. AND OUR
KIDS I'VE GOT FIVE CHILDREN AND
I STILL COLUMN CHILDREN OF ALL
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE THEY HAVE
FRIENDS AND WIVES IN HUSBANDS
THAT ARE. MIX FROM ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES- AND I THINK HOW
IMPORTANT AT THAT STUDIES IS
RIGHT NOW WE HEAR ABOUT TIMING.
MISTER BRADFORD THANK YOU
BECAUSE TIME IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT. WE CANNOT. LET THE
SENATE. TAKE A STEP BACK WE'VE
GOT TO GO FORWARD AS A UNIT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IS NOT ABOUT
MONEY IT'S ABOUT SENSITIVITY
IT'S ABOUT THE LEADERSHIP AND
OF OUR FUTURE THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE IN COLLEGE TODAY WHO
ARE ABOUT TO TAKE THE HELM OVER
THE NEXT TEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
YEARS THEY'VE GOT TO SEE AND
THEY'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND. TO
BE THE SENSITIVITY BUT THEY
MUST HAVE IT LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
SEE THAT RIGHT NOW IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
SENSITIVITY AND THE KNOWLEDGE
OF THE COMMUNITY TO BE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
AND WHEN WE TAKE AWAY THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL FOR MORE
COLLEGES AND HERE'S THE THING
IN ISN'T IT TRUE THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS WILL BE
COLLEGE GRADUATES MORE
IMPORTANTLY PROBABLY FROM
THERE- NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE CAL
STATE SYSTEM. PROBABLY FROM
EAST LA PROBABLY FROM SOUTH
CENTRAL GUARDINO WHEREVER THEY
MIGHT BE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
OUR LEADERS OF THE FUTURE FROM
THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEY HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND SENSITIVITY
ACROSS THE BOARD SO ETHNIC
STUDIES IS NOT JUST- SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO THROW
BECAUSE OF THE COST OR NO COST
WHATEVER IT'S A NECESSITY IN
TODAY'S WORLD. IN TODAY'S WORLD
WHAT IS HAPPENING WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD
UNDERSTANDS THE WORK SPACE
DIGNITY HONOR IN THAT HONOR
THROW THAT OUT TO YOU AS OUR
MEN WERE WERE SERVING IN THE-
THERE ARE SO MANY MINORITY IN
THE MILITARY TO MEET. FOR WHAT
THEY DO IS THERE A FRONT FIND.
AND SENSITIVE. WE'RE GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR HE- DOWN THE-
FOR PROMOTIONS IT ALL WITH YOU
THIS AND I'VE THIS SENATOR. SO
THAT IN THE END STATES MAY. A
THE- WE HAVE. I'M SO WE HAVE
FOR TWO FOUR STAR GENERALS.
FORTY TWO FOUR STAR GENERALS.
AND WE ONLY HAD ONE AFRICAN
AMERICAN FOR YEARS NOW WE JUST
HAVE THE SECOND. CAN YOU
IMAGINE THAT FORTY TWO FOUR
STAR GENERALS AND NOW. LOOK AT
ALL THE YEARS OF CON BY NOW WE
HAVE FINALLY HAVE TO. WELL WHAT
ABOUT THE LATINOS WHAT ABOUT
ASIANS WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE OF ALL
MIXTURES. IT IS TIME THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE THE STEP FORWARD WE
HAVE TO DO IT AS A UNIT. AND BE
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT THIS ALL
MEANS SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE AND
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
MISTER PRESIDENT. IT IS ARE
JULY SENT BELL. MEMBERS ARE I
REPRESENT ONE OF THE LARGEST.
UNIVERSITIES SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND LAST YEAR I
WENT TO THE CELEBRATION OF OUR
FIFTIETH. ANNIVERSARY OF OUR
BLACK STUDIES PROGRAM AND I
READ INTO ONE OF MY PROFESSORS
DR. STEPHEN MILNER WHO IS
CHAIRMAN OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND
HE JOKED ABOUT HOW IT WAS A
FAIR TO MIDDLING STUDENT YOU
KNOW BUT- HE SHARED WITH ME.
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HISTORY
OVER THE YEARS. OF THEM
NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS. TO A
ACTUALLY ELIMINATE THE
DEPARTMENT. TO REDUCE THE SCOPE
OR THE DEPARTMENT REDUCE THE
FACULTY. AND I KNOW ALSO THERE
ARE THE SAME THING HAPPENED TO
THE MAX AMERICAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT IS SENT TO THE STATE
OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT CONSIDERED A CORD APARTMENT.
THERE WERE NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS
EVERY TIME THERE WAS A BUDGET
PROBLEM. LIKE WE HAVE NOW. TO
ELIMINATE OR REMOVE THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
A VERY PROUD HERITAGES OUT OF
THE STATE. WITH DOCTOR GALARZA.
CREATING THE DEPARTMENT AT SAN
JOSE STATE. AND I'M ROSE. THE
EMPHASIS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOCIAL WORKERS- THOUSANDS OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND GRADUATED
THERE. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TEACHERS. PSYCHOLOGY. EVEN
URBAN STUDIES POLITICAL SCIENCE
LIKE MYSELF. GRADUATE DEGREES.
IN THE HUMANITIES AND ARTS.
BECAUSE THIS IS PARTIALLY ABOUT
THAT ALSO WAS ABOUT NOT JUST
HISTORY IT'S ABOUT. YOU'RE
LEARNING ABOUT. HUMANITIES AND
ARTS. AND WE HAVE A PROBLEM
DEPARTMENT- THAT TEACHES THAT
THAT'S WITH THOSE DEPARTMENTS
TEACH. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THESE DEPARTMENTS IN THIS DAY
AND AGE OR ESSENTIAL THERE
SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED. LIKE
THE MOST RECENT TIME THEY CALL
THEY TALKED ABOUT SCALING BACK
THE DEPARTMENT. IT ACTUALLY
WASN'T THAT LIKE TWENTY YEARS
AGO IT WAS ONLY LIKE FIVE YEARS
AGO. THEY TRIED TO ELIMINATE
THE DEPARTMENT FIVE YEARS AGO.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT. THAT'S
A PATTERN EVERY TIME EVERY TIME
THERE'S A BUDGET PROBLEM THEY
ALWAYS LOOK AT THE PARCHMENTS
THAT OR NOT THE COURT
APARTMENTS. THE REPEAT THE
MANDATED DEPARTMENTS FOR YOUR
BASIC EDUCATION AND THEY
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE OF. AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT. SHOULD
HAVE THE STATUS. OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT'S ESSENTIAL TO
THE UNIVERSITIES BEING. WHICH
IS THE WAY ACTUALLY THE
STUDENTS LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT.
YOU TALK TO THE STUDENTS THEY
THANK FIFTIES DEPARTMENTS ARE
ESSENTIAL WHEN THEY WALK BY. SO
THE STATE THE TWENTY FIVE FOOT
HIGH STATUE OF. TOMMY SMITH AND
JOHN CARLOS. THERE WE HAVE IT
SET OUT OF THE STATE. AND
REMEMBER THE HERITAGE. OF OUR
UNIVERSITY THEY HAPPEN TO BE
ONE I WENT TO SCHOOL THERE WHEN
THESE DEPARTMENTS WERE PARADED.
AND THE STRUGGLE SURGE PARADE
ON. GIVEN THE FACT THAT. THE
PROTESTS RESULTED IN. THE
REACTION OF POLITICIANS TO
ELIMINATE THOSE DEPARTMENTS AT
THAT TIME. SO IT SEEMS TO ME IT
SEEMS TO ME. THAT WE HAVE TO
REALLY LOOK AT WHAT REALLY IS
GOING ON HERE. IF WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE THIS A CORE. OF
OUR UNIVERSITY AND A CORE OF
OUR EDUCATION OF THE TEACHERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS THE BUSINESS
PEOPLE THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
HERE IN THIS BUILDING OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. TO HAVE A CULTURAL
HAPPENS EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT
THE CULTURAL COMPETENCY SHOULD
BE A- BASIC NORM. IN OUR
SOCIETY. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE
OUGHT TO HAVE THE STUDENTS TO
GET DEGREES IN. POLICE IN ALL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IT WOULD BE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRAM THERE.
WE SHOULD HAVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN OUR STUDENTS. AND
THAT'S WHY. I AGREE WITH THE-
CENTER FROMGARDENIA I THINK WE
HAVE A PASS THAT'S NOT GOOD. WE
SHOULD CORRECT THAT PASS IN
ADJUSTED THIS IS WHY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. VIRGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BILL CENTER
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT OF A QUESTION OF THE
A FLOOR MANAGER PLEASE. DEBORAH
FOR YOU CHECK A QUESTION. I
HAVE TO THANK YOU- WOULD COULD
CLEAR FIVE ME IF THIS
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO THE DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENT WE HEARD OUR
COLLEAGUE TALK ABOUT OR WOULD
IT REPLACE IT. IN BEEN DISHING
TO IN ADDITION TO OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I ON MY OWN TIME
IF I MAY MISTER PRESIDENT
COURSE- THIS IS BEEN AT. THE
LIGHTNING AND AN INFORMATIVE
AND HELPFUL DEBATE FOR ME I
THINK THEY'RE JUST A COUPLE
THINGS I DON'T WANT TO BE
REDUNDANT TERMS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID YOU KNOW
ONE THING THAT STRUCK ME AS I
SAT HERE AND LISTENED AYE I
THOUGHT BACK TO MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN ETHNIC STUDIES IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE. AND
WHAT I'D ALWAYS STRUCK ME IT
WAS ALWAYS STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO DID THE CLASSES. THE
MAJORITY STUDENTS THEY JUST
WEREN'T THERE THAT MAY BE MY-
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCE. AND AS
WE LOOK AT THE CHALLENGES AND
EXPERIENCES WERE HAVING TODAY
PRIMARILY WITH. CONVINCING
OTHERS ABOUT THE LIFE
EXPERIENCE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
THAT'S HALF THE CHALLENGE AND
WE HAVE SO MANY DEBATES ON THE
FLOOR SO MANY TIMES THAT NOW IS
THE NOT THE RIGHT TIME LET'S
COLLECT DATA WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY. AND THIS IS OUR EFFORT
TO POUR INTO THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA INFORMATION SO WE
CAN GET BEYOND. ON THE NEED TO
RE EDUCATE THE MAJORITY.
TEMPORARILY ARM ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES OF PEOPLE OF COVER
EVERY TIME THAT THERE'S A
CHALLENGE IT IS A CONVERSATION
WE HAVE TO START FROM THE
BEGINNING. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FUTURE LEADERS OF OUR GREAT
STATE- ARE BETTER THAN WE ARE.
THAT'S MY HOPE. MY HOPE IS THAT
THESE GRADUATING STUDENTS WILL
COME ON AND BE THE FUTURE
LEADERS THE FUTURE CORPORATE
LEADERS BUSINESS LEADERS AND SO
WE CAN STEP AWAY FROM HAVING TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND
VALIDATING WIDE DIVERSITY HELPS
YOUR BUSINESS WHY DIVERSE
CAMPUS. IS HEALTHY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS. THE
CATALOG OF OFFERINGS IS NOT THE
ISSUE. ALTHOUGH I WAS INTRIGUED
TO SEE CHICO STATE IN THEIR
DIVERSITY- REQUIREMENTS AT A
COURSE ENTITLED. HEALTH AT
EVERY SIZE A NON DIET APPROACH
TO WELLNESS. SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT DIVERSITY VERSES ETHNIC
STUDIES THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE AND WHAT WE ARGUING
IS THE IMPORTANCE OF A SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION AROUND RACE THAT'S
WHAT ETHNIC STUDIES BRINGS TO
THE TABLE. BECAUSE I.
APPRECIATE BUT I PROBABLY COULD
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THE HEALTH
EVERY SIZE AND ON THAT APPROACH
TO WELLNESS AND PERHAPS SHOULD
HAVE TAKEN IT- AND THEIR PEOPLE
I'M SURE WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM
THAT BUT LET'S NOT CONFUSE THE
IMPORTANT VALUE OF
CONVERSATIONS AROUND DIVERSITY
WITH A CORE CURRICULUM ABOUT
ETHNIC STUDIES THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE. AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THERE IS SPACE IN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BY BOTH. I
APPRECIATE THAT ARE CSU SYSTEM
MAY BE ONE OF THE DIVERSE MOST
DIVERSE IN THE WORLD BUT LET'S
BE CLEAR COMPARED TO WHAT
HIGHER ACADEMIA IS ONE OF THE
LEAST THE FIRST. SECTORS IN THE
WORLD. AND SO IT MAY BE ONE OF
THE MOST DIVERSE BUT IS IT
TRULY REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
MOST DIVERSE STATE. THE OTHER
CHALLENGE IS PIPELINE ISSUES
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS AN
UNDERGRAD ALBEIT A MILLION
YEARS AGO. MOST OF THE TENURED
PROFESSORS THAT WE LOOK TO AS
EXAMPLES THAT WE COULD GO TO
FOR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT. WERE
IN THE ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN JOSE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE MINUTE THAT THERE IS ANY
KIND OF FINANCIAL UP A
CHALLENGE TO UNIVERSITY THOSE
DEPARTMENTS ARE DOWNGRADED TO
PROGRAMS THEY DON'T BACK FEEL
VACANCIES BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A
TENURE TRACK FOR PROFESSORS AND
SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
IT. A DIVERSE INSTITUTION AND
BE ABLE TO HIRE FROM WITHIN
THERE IN LIES THE PROBLEM. I'M
NOT SURE HOW ANY OF US CAN
GUARANTEE OR BE CONFIDENT ABOUT
WHAT ANOTHER APPOINTED BODY
WILL DO. FIND OUT. WHAT I DO
KNOW IS WHAT'S WHAT A SIGNAL
THIS WILL SEND. TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE SAYS THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
ARE WILLING TO SET THE
PRECEDENT BY MAKING IT A
MANDATE I AM CLEAR WHAT KIND OF
SIGNAL THAT WILL SEND TO THE
TRUSTEES IN THEIR DELIBERATIONS
THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS FOR YEARS. AND HAVE FAILED.
ANSEL VOTE TODAY WILL ALLOW THE
BILL TO STAY ALIVE AND
HOPEFULLY- SEND A STRONG SIGNAL
ABOUT OUR EXPECTATIONS ABOUT
THE CORE VALUE. OF THIS KIND OF
EDUCATION I'LL BE SUPPORTING
MAYBE FOURTEEN SIXTY TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
BY STOP THE STAND AS WELL AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AS WELL AS SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT CERTAINLY LONG
OVERDUE THE TIME IS NOW YOU'VE
HEARD THIS MANY TIMES- BUT THIS
IS REALLY. A BILL THAT WILL NOT
ONLY PREPARES FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS THIS IS A
BILL PRODUCED AND WANTED AND
NEEDED BY OUR STUDENTS MOST OF
WHICH TERMINATE MINORITY
STUDENTS. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
WITH DEEP STRUCTURE STRUGGLE
AND PERSEVERANCE AND THEY DID
BETTER WHEN THEY DID. STUDENTS
WHO IDENTIFIED LITTLE WITH
THEIR OWN ETHNIC GROUP ACHIEVED
POORLY. OVERWHELMING DOMINANCE
OF EURO AMERICAN PERSPECTIVES.
THE MANY STUDENTS TO DISENGAGE
FROM CREATIVE ARE I'M SORRY
FROM ACADEMIC LEARNING. IT'S
NOT JUST AN ACADEMIC VALUE IT'S
A SOCIAL VALUE INVALUABLE. AND
JUST AS WE SOUGHT TO IMPORTANT-
SUPREME COURT DECISIONS LGBT Q.
AMERICANS WERE PROTECTED IN THE
WORKPLACE AND DHAKA'S. DREAMERS
WERE PROTECTED WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THOSE DECISIONS IN
OUR HISTORY BOOKS. OVERALL THIS
PROVIDES A SPACE MINORITY
STUDENTS FEEL THEIR HERITAGE
HOUSE WORTH. YES WE KNOW THE
IMMIGRATION AND STRUGGLES WITH
IMMIGRATION AND STRUGGLES
WITHIN JUST AS SLAVERY ARE PART
OF THAT HISTORY THEY ALSO NEED
TO KNOW THAT THE SUCCESSES OF
OUR LEADERS ARE PART OF THAT
HISTORY TO. IN ADDITION THE
INTERSECTION ALLEY OF WOMEN OF
COLOR WHO ARE OFTEN NOT IN
THESE BOOKS AND OVERLOOKED. IN
PAID LESS AND NOT EVEN VISIBLE
IN THESE BOOKS SHOULD ALSO BE
INCLUDED. SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN I ASK
YOU COLLEAGUES TO MAKE THIS A
VERY IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR US
WE DON'T MAKE THIS DECISION NOW
IT'S THAT SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
GONZALEZ CENTER LEYVA. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS- I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WHEN I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- DOCTOR WEBER HAS BEEN
TENACIOUS ON THIS ISSUE AND
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
HEARING BILL SIMILAR TO THIS
SINCE I'VE BEEN ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR THE
LAST SIX YEARS. MEMBERS WE CAN
ALWAYS FIND A WAY NOT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S THE EASIEST
THING TO DO IS TO SAY NO AND WE
CAN MAKE EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE
AFTER EXCUSE. WHAT'S HARD TO
DO. IS FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE DO
THE RIGHT THING. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. IT IS LONG OVERDUE.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE COST IN
THAT THE IN THE UNIVERSITIES
CAN'T WIN KERR THE COSTS NOW.
WELL I THINK WE CAN ALWAYS
BLAME COSTS EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
IN A GOING INTO A RECESSION NOW
BUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE COST
OF DOING NOTHING. IS MORE
EXPENSIVETHAN THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS. WE ALL LEARN
WHAT WE LIVE AT HOME AND GUESS
WHAT. SOMETIMES RACISM IS TOP
RIGHT THERE IN SOMEONE'S LIVING
ROOM. SO IF WE DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOPE FOR THE FUTURE. TO LEARN
ABOUT OTHER ETHNICITIES HOW DO
WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T SEE THAT
WHEN WE UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER
WERE MOR ACCEPTING OF EACH
OTHER WHEN WE UNDERSTAND EACH
OTHER WE REALIZE WE HAVE MORE
IN COMMON. THAN NOT. AND I HAVE
TO ALSO SAY THAT DIVERSITY IN
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS. AND I HAVE
TO. STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A RENDA. ANIM
SOMEWHAT OFFENDED WHEN HE
APPLIED THE PEOPLE ON HIS SIDE
OF THE AISLE. WHICH I'M NOT
SURE WHAT WAS ON THE SAME SIDE
OF THE AISLE. THAT WE ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF A SITUATION
TO VOTE ON THIS. YOU KNOW WHAT
I'VE SUPPORTED ETHNIC STUDIES
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE WE
HAVE WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
RIGHTLY SO IN THE STREETS. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT YES THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS IN JANUARY.
CAME OUT WITH THIS IDEA THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IN ETHNIC
STUDIES BUT WHAT. PEOPLE FAIL
TO MENTION IS THAT THREE YEARS
AGO THE C. ISSUES DID A STUDY
THEIR OWN STUDY AND CONCLUDED
THAT THEY NEEDED TO ADD ETHNIC
STUDIES. TO THEIR CURRICULUM
THEY DIDN'T DO IT I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE ONLY REASON THEY'RE
DOING IT NOW OR SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IT. IS BECAUSE OF
DOC RIVERS BILL BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL SO WE CAN'T LET THEM OFF
THE HOOK. I LOVE OR RC ISSUES
AND I THINK THEY DO FABULOUS
WORK. BUT SOMETIMES THEY HAVE
TO BE PUSHED A LITTLE BIT. I
THINK WE CAN WORRY ABOUT
PRESIDENT. BUT SOMETIMES. IF WE
JUST HIDE BEHIND THAT. WE DON'T
GET THE RIGHT THING DONE. SO
MANY IN WAS SOMETHING. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE VISUAL
LEARNERS I WOULD ASK YOU TO
WATCH A MOVIE AND YOU MIGHT SAY
CONNIE LEIVA THAT SEEMS VERY AN
ACADEMIC ASKING US O WATCH A
MOVIE I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
WATCH REMEMBER THE TITANS. AND
THE REASON I ASK YOU TO WATCH
THAT MOVIE IS BECAUSE IT'S
BASED ON A TRUE STORY AND WHEN
YOU LOOK T HOW DIVIDED THAT
FOOTBALL TEAM WAS WHITES AND
BLACKS AND WHEN DENZEL
WASHINGTON COULD THEIR COACH
SAYS I'M GONNA MAKE EACH OF YOU
SPEND TIME TOGETHER AND LEARN
ABOUT EACH OTHER WHAT HAPPENED
THEY ENDED UP WITH A PERFECT
SEASON. I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT
IT'S OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THEY'RE
GOING TO CHANGE THIS WORLD WHEN
YOU ALSO WATCH THAT MOVIE YOU
WILL SEE THAT IT IS THE ADULTS
IT IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUR
AGE ON THIS FLOOR WHO ARE THE
PROBLEM LET'S NOT BE THE
PROBLEM LET'S BE THE SOLUTION
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY LET'S
TAKE IT I STRONGLY SUPPORT. AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY. THANK YOU SIR
LABOR CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I'M IN
REVIEWING THE FLOOR ANALYSES
FOR THIS BILL WHILE WE WERE
DEBATING AND I'M I'M NOT
FINDING SOMETHING SO MAY I. ASK
A QUESTION OF THE FLOOR MANAGER.
MISTER BRADFORD WE TAKE A
QUESTION NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL THROUGH
THE CHAIR CENTER MORE LIKE YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS
SPECIFIC TO SEE A- AND- MY NOW
WE ALSO SEE THAT IT MY BE A TO
THE CAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE
SO WE HAVE STUDENTS BUT IT IS
NOT APPLICABLE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO I'M-
AREAS HAVE THEY'RE READY
IMPLEMENTED THIS POLICY. I'M
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF NO WE
STARTED AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY- THAT WAS THOUGHT TO
WORKERS DESERVE RESEARCH ON THE
YEAH. WE DO HAVE I'VE BEEN
STILL WE HAVE HIGH. OKAY YOU
SEE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY AND SO WE HAVE NO WITH TO
DEMAND A RE. CURRICULUM FROM
THE- UNIVERSITY THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I'M A SORT OF
A NO BETTER NO WORSE I. WOULD
CERTAINLY A WE WERE TO IT FOR
SYSTEM MAKE DO IT FOR THE-OTHERS FOR I PRE THE CALL I'M
ONE OF THOSE. THAT BELIEVES
THAT MANAGER SHOULD MANAGE SO I
ARE ARE ARE VERY APPRECIATE.
THE FLOOR SPEECH PROVIDED BY
THE SENATOR FOR MARANDA HIGH. I
THINK WE SHOULD TAKE HIS
COMMENTS TO HEART THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR
MORE LIKE CENTER HUESO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AWAY AND JUST
SO VERY BRIEFLY. YOU KNOW I
DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEM. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WEIGHING IN ON ON
THE ISSUE OF EDUCATION IN OUR
STATE. IN ANY REGARD NOW
WHATEVER THE OVER THE DEBATE IS
THAT SO I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BUT MOSTLY. MY MAIN
CONCERN OF OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
I'VE OFTEN ASKED THIS. OF THE
LEADERS OF OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
ASKED THEM WHAT S YOUR
MISSION. DO YOU HAVE A MISSION
WHAT IS YOUR PRIMARY MISSION IF
YOU WERE TO DESCRIBE WHAT YOU
ARE THERE TO DO AND THE
UNIVERSITY. WHAT IS IT. OFTEN I
GET DIFFERENT RESULTS RESPONSES
AND THAT OFTEN CONCERNS ME.
BECAUSE WHEN INDIVIDUALS
RUNNING OUR UNIVERSITIES DON'T
AGREE ON WHAT THEIR MISSION IS.
THERE ARE GENERALLY GOING TO
GET DIFFERENT OUTCOMES AND I'VE
HEARD THINGS FROM TO- MAKE
BETTER PEOPLE OF OUR STUDENTS
TO. PROVIDE THEM WITH A BETTER
FUTURE. A GENERAL ANSWERS. AND
I ALWAYS RESPOND. WITH WITH A
QUESTION OF SHOULDN'T WE HAVE
VERY CLEAR GOALS SET OUT OF OUR
UNIVERSITY SO WE KNOW WHAT THE
GOAL IS SO THAT WE CAN MEASURE
WHETHER WE'RE ACCOMPLISHING OUR
GOAL. AND I ALWAYS ASK HIM
ISN'T OUR GOAL TO CREATE OF OUR
STUDENTS. CRITICAL THINKERS AND
WHAT IS A CRITICAL THINKER
SOMEBODY THAT CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENTIFIC
METHOD. SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS
WHAT IT IS AND HOW TO EMPLOY IT.
BECAUSE OF THE SCIENTIFIC
METHOD THAT'S HOW WE HAVE. OF
PUT UP. OF PEOPLE ON THE MOON.
INTO SPACE HOW WE HAVE BUILT
SKYSCRAPERS AND- A MAKE UP AN
AIRPLANE FLY. AND IF WE ARE
PREPARING CALIFORNIANS TO BE
CRITICAL THINKERS. THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER EVERY QUESTION
ON THEIR OWN. AND SO I HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WORK OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING AND I
HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
OUR OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH IT.
AND I APPRECIATE OF. THE OTHERS
CENTER LIVE I'M SORRY MENTION
YOUR MAN NAMED BUT YOU BEAT ME
TO THE PUNCH ON RECOMMENDED
MOVIE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
RECOMMEND A MOVIE. AND IT'S A
MOVIE THAT I SAW THAT REALLY
CHANGED MY VIEW ON. THE AYE AYE
THAT THAT PEOPLE ARE MUTABLE
PEOPLE ARE CHANGEABLE PEOPLE
CAN BE INFLUENCE WITH AN
EDUCATION. FULL OF HAVE HUMAN
QUALITIES THAT CAN BE INFLUENCE
TO CHANGE THEIR VIEWS ABOUT.
HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE THIS MOVIE IS CALLED THE
BEST OF ENEMIES. AND IT TALKS
ABOUT A CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER
AND- ATWATER. AND THE LEADER OF
THE GRAND MASTER OF THE KLU
KLUX KLAN. A CP ELLIS. WHO WERE
BROUGHT TOGETHER AS PART OF A.
PUBLISHED A SURE- A CHARRETTE
COMMUNITY CHARETTE. TWO DISK
THE INTEGRATION SCHOOLS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. AND HOW CP
ELLIS BEING THE DIRECTOR CLICK
CLICK FIND WOULD NEVER ACCEPT
INTEGRATION. UNTIL HE WAS PUT
THROUGH A PROCESS TO
UNDERSTAND. THE OTHER THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE COMMUNITY AND TO
VISIT AND TO SEE THAT THERE
WERE PEOPLE THEY HAD FEELINGS
AND THEY DESERVE AN EDUCATION I
KNEW HE WAS THE DECIDING VOTE.
TO INTEGRATE THE SCHOOLS. AND
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND IT'S
JUST A FASCINATING MOVIE THE
SHOWS THAT. EDUCATION IS
CRITICAL TO CHANGING. THE PATH
OF OUR COUNTRY. AND IF IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WHY ARE WE PUTTING
MORE AND OF AN EMPHASIS OF BIG
GIVING PEOPLE. AN EDUCATION THE
QUESTIONS THEM IN THEIR COMFORT
ZONE. MAKE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE
MAKE THEM LEARN. IF THEY ARE
GOING TO THE UNIVERSITY'S
CHALLENGE THEIR MINDS AND
CHALLENGE THEIR THEIR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORLD TO
WEAR THAT COULD AFFECT THEIR
CORE BELIEFS. THIS IS A VERY
POWERFUL BILL. THIS THIS GETS
TO JUST SIMPLY PROVIDING OUR
STUDENTS WITH AN EDUCATION NOT
INDOCTRINATING THEM MAKING THEM
CRITICAL THINKERS MAKE UP YOUR
OWN MIND BUT WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THE INFORMATION IN FRONT OF YOU.
TEN AND LEARN HOW TO DISSECT IT
ON YOUR OWN WE ARE MAKING
SCIENTISTS OF OUR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THERE THE FUTURE OF
OUR ECONOMY TO THE FUTURE OF
OUR WORLD. IF WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE RIGHT EDUCATION THE
WORLD WILL BE A BETTER PLACE.
AND THEY WILL BE MORE
EMPLOYABLE. AND THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO UNITE OUR COUNTRY. TWO I
MEAN I'VE VISITED OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT ARE UNITED ON
RACIAL ISSUES AND THEY ARE
POWERFUL COUNTRIES ECONOMICALLY.
WE ARE SUFFERING FROM MARCH A
CANCER THAT IS HURTING OUR VERY
ECONOMIC SYSTEM LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN LET'S CHALLENGE THAT
LET'S ASK OUR UNIVERSITIES. TO
CHALLENGE THEIR STUDENTS AND
BRING UP. A IT'S A SUBJECT THAT
SENSITIVE YES IT'S
CONTROVERSIAL SENSITIVE IT'S
GONNA MAKE PEOPLE. UNEASY LET'S
CHALLENGE OUR STUDENTS PLEASE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. THANK YOU
SIR HUESO SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. AFFECT MY THOUGHTS
TOGETHER BECAUSE I THINK. MOST
OF US ON THIS FLOOR PERHAPS ALL
THIS JUST WITH EVERYTHING WE
HAVE BEEN OBSERVING IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS HAVE A LOT OF
STRONG FEELINGS ABOUT NOT ONLY
THE ISSUE WE'RE DEBATING TODAY
BUT SO MANY OF THE THINGS THAT.
WE HAVE HAD NEW SPOT LIGHTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENT YES FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS BUT NEW
SPOTLIGHTS ADDED. I REMEMBER AS
A SECOND OR THIRD GRADER IN
CATHOLIC SCHOOL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN MY RELIGION CLASS
WHEN WE LEARNED ABOUT THE MARK
ON CAIN. CAME THE BROTHER WHO
KILLED ABLE. WELL MY TEACHER
DIDN'T SAY IT. EXPLICITLY IT
WAS HINTED AND I UNDERSTOOD AND
THEN LATER AT SOME POINT AT THE
DINNER TABLE IN MY FAMILY. THE
IMPLICATION WAS THAT BLACK
PEOPLE ARE DESCENDANTS OF CAIN
THE MARK OF CAIN WAS ON BLACK
PEOPLE THEY'RE BLACK SKIN WAS
GOD'S MARK. I'LL UP THE CURRENT
REFERENCE TO CAME AND THIS IS
WHAT IT'S- THE CURRENT
REFERENCE. SOME TRADITIONAL
BIBLICAL RELIGIOUS
INTERPRETATIONS CONSIDER CAME
TO BE THE ORIGINATOR OF EVIL
VIOLENCE FOR FREE. THIS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE SUBTLE.
EXPLICIT AND OTHERWISE
PERVASIVE WAYS MY GROWING UP AS
A WHITE AMERICAN STEEP TO ME IN
ACCEPTING AN NOT QUESTIONING
SYSTEMIC RACISM I DID NOT EVEN
UNDERSTAND IT. NOTE THE WORD
TRADITION THROUGHOUT MY GROWING
UP AS AN AMERICAN WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK IS STILL
TRUE TODAY. AMERICAN CULTURAL
TRADITIONS BECAUSE THOSE
CULTURAL TRADITIONS WERE
DEVELOPED BY WHITE AMERICANS
EXPLICITLY REINFORCE RACISM.
AGAINST NATIVE AMERICANS
AGAINST BLACKS AGAINST LACK
NECKS. AND STE SO MANY OTHERS
IN REINFORCE THE CANE STORY
WITHOUT EXPLICITLY SAYING IT.
NOW ADMITTEDLY MY SECOND GRADE
WAS A LONG TIME AGO AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT NO CHILD IN
AMERICA IS TALKED SUCH AS I
WAS. BUT OUR REMIND US THAT
THIS UNDERSTANDING A RELIGIOUS
TRADITION AND SOMETHING THAT I
COULD FIND EASILY RIGHT NOW
WHEN I STARTED TO LOOK IT UP. I
COULD RELATE VERY SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES THOUGH NOT THE
POLITICAL REFERENCES OR MAYBE I
HAVEN'T LOOKED HARD ENOUGH
ABOUT WHAT SHAPED MY PERCEPTION
OF MEXICAN AMERICANS. THE VERY
TOWN WERE MY CATHOLIC SCHOOL
WAS LOCATED DID NOT ALLOW
BLACKS MEXICANS ASIANS OR JEWS
TO BUY HOUSES. MOST EVERY
NEIGHBORHOOD HAD RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS DID ANYONE EXPLAIN
THAT TO ME DID I LEARN ABOUT
THAT IN ANY CLASS. DID ANYONE
EVER MENTION. THE NC LORRAINE
DOES EVERYBODY YOU LIVE YOUR
LIFE JUST LIKE YOU AND ME NOW.
THIS LEARNING THAT BE SIXTY
WOULD. IS A SAY. WE AND WHAT WE
DO IN UNDER. OR WHAT WE DO NOT.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY EXPRESSLY
THE REQUIRED ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE ADDRESS SPECIFIC
ETHNICITIES AND SPECIFIC
TRADITIONS IN AMERICA. BUT
ADDRESSING OTHER. BUT FOR MY
POINT OF VIEW A ROUTER IF I
LOOK AND I READ BILL NO WE'RE
IN THE- DOES IT SAY. THAT THE
COURSE UNDER FOURTEEN SIXTY
MOST EXCLUDE. ARIEL THAT REALLY
GIVES BACK FOR UNDERSTAND. OF
THE INTEREST OF ALL OF THE WAY
THAT YOU OR LAW OR HEY. AFFECT
THE DIVERSITY AND SOCIAL OF
THOSE ETHNICITIES SO ANOTHER
WORDS IT IS NOT EXPLICITLY. THE
FACT THAT OTHERS. HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY HAVE EXPERIENCE BIAS
AND DISCRIMINATION AND STILL TO
TODAY AS WE KNOW SO MANY. OTHER
JEWISH MUSLIM SEAT. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY REQUIRES THE COURSE
ADDRESS DIVERSITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE HISTORY A GOOD
CURRICULUM THAT ADDRESSES THE
DIVERSITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
HISTORY OF THE US WILL DESCRIBE
HOW MANY OF THE SAME LAWS THAT
I DESCRIBED TRADITIONS AND
PRACTICES. WERE ALSO ANTI
SEMITIC FOR EXAMPLE WERE AIMED
AT CHOOSE. AND IN I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT SUCH A COURSE
WOULD NOT ADDRESS HOW EACH TIME
WE SEE AN INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES WHETHER AGAINST BLACKS
LET NEXT PEOPLE. WE SEE LIKE
NOW EIGHT INCREASE IN ANTI
SEMITIC ACTIONS SO THE
INCORPORATION OF SUCH ISSUE
SOME PARALLELS WOULD TO MY MIND
NATURALLY BE INCLUDED IN SUCH A
COURSE. SO I SEE AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY AS A PATH TO PROVIDING AN
EDUCATION ON ALL ASPECTS OF THE
UNITED STATES SYSTEMIC
APPLICATION OF BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION. AND WHILE MY
COLLEAGUE DINNER FOR MARIN TO
RACED BACK FORTUNATELY THERE
ARE MANY GOOD COURSE OFFERINGS
AT OUR CS. THESE ARE ELECTED.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY INSURERS THAT
THE EDUCATION WE OFFER AT THIS
GREAT PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND THE STUDENTS THAT
ATTEND WILL RECEIVE THE BENEFIT
OF THIS LEARNING. MY HOPE FOR
THE EXPANSION OF THIS
EDUCATIONAL OFFERING IS THAT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL HAVE
MUCH MORE INFORMED DISCUSSION.
ON ISSUES LIKE THE HISTORY AND
ORIGINS OF POLICING THE HISTORY
AND ORIGIN OF THE LABOR LAWS
AGRICULTURAL LABOR LAWS FOR
EXAMPLE WHY ARE NEIGHBORHOODS
LOOK LIKE THEY DO. SECOND MAN
INFORM OUR DEBATE ON SUCH
ISSUES AS AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND SO
MUCH MORE. I WISH THAT I HAD
HAD SUCH A CLASS I WOULD BE A
BETTER PERSON TODAY BY- TO VOTE
ON AB FOURTEEN SIXTY. THANK YOU
CENTER STAGE. A SCANNER SO%
ALLEN. MEMBERS SAID I AGREE
WITH SO MUCH OF WHAT'S BEEN
SAID ON THE FLOOR TODAY-
THERE'S SO MUCH WISDOM THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN EXPRESSED. THE
VALUE IN THE HISTORY OF ETHNIC
STUDIES IN THIS PARTICULAR
HISTORY WITH REGARDS TO THE CAL
STATE SYSTEM AND ETHNIC STUDIES
IS SO SPECIAL AND SOMETHING
THAT WE OUGHT TO BE PROUD OF IS
CALIFORNIANS- THE FACT IS THAT
THIS WAS A MOVEMENT THAT REALLY
WAS SPURRED. BY STUDENTS AND
SOME YOUNG FACULTY GRADUATE
STUDENTS AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE- BACK IN THE SIXTIES AS
PART OF SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT WERE DESCRIBED BY BY SOME
MY COLLEAGUES. AND YOU KNOW I
GOT TO SAY I PERSONALLY
BENEFITED A GREAT DEAL FROM
THAT MOVEMENT BECAUSE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. OF STUDYING I TOOK
SEVERAL CLASSES ENOUGH AMERICAN
STUDIES AS AN UNDERGRADUATE I
TOOK A LATINO CULTURES CLASS
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY STUDY THE
CREDIT PROFESSOR DR GOING OUT
WEST BEEN A GUY BACK ON MY
LESSONS IN ITS- FROM THAT.
COURSE ALL THE TIME. AND HELPS
ME. GET BETTER AND- OF- THE
RICHEST OF OUR COUNTRY IN THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WE- REALLY DO-
UNDER. UNDER EXAMINE. SO MUCH
OF THE- THE COMMON NARRATIVE
THAT IS HANDED DOWN TO US.
ABOUT AMERICAN HISTORY. AND
THERE'S SO MUCH TO EXAMINE
THERE IS SO MUCH TO EXAMINE-
AND- EVERYTHING FROM- THE FACT
THAT. THE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
THAT PICTURE. AT IN UTAH WHERE
THEY- CELEBRATE THE
CONSTRUCTION AND THE COMPLETION
OF THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD. AND IS NOT A SINGLE
ASIAN AMERICAN FACE IN THAT
PICTURE. EVEN THOUGH WE ALL
KNOW THAT. MOST OF THE
CONSTRUCTION LEASE THE WESTERN
PORTION OF THE WELL ROAD WAS
DONE ON PRIMARILY BY CHINESE
AMERICANS WHO REALLY SUFFERED
IN LABOR UNDER INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT CONDITIONS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT THAN THE FOLKS
BUILDING FROM THE FROM THE
EAST. I YEAH WE REALLY YOU KNOW
I THINK A LOT OF MY OWN
COLLEAGUES PROBABLY DON'T
REALIZE THAT THERE WAS
EFFECTIVELY A STATE SPONSORED
GENOCIDE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES AGAINST NEEDED
CALIFORNIANS NATIVE AMERICANS.
AND THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE
PROFESSOR DOWN TO UCLA WHO
INTERESTINGLY IS A MEMBER OF
BOTH THE HISTORY DEPARTMENT
AND- THE AMERICAN INDIAN
STUDIES. DEPARTMENT THAT'S WHAT
THEY CALL THEIR- WHO WROTE IN
AMAZING BUT THAT- I GOT ON MY
RADAR SCREEN BECAUSE IT JERRY
BROWN GIVEN THE SPEECH ABOUT IT
A HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY A
COUPLE YEARS BACK THAT I. NOW
HAVE IN REFERENCE- HI. YEAH
THERE ARE SO MANY STORIES THERE
ARE SO MANY STORIES AND GET
UNDER TOLD AN UNDER APPRECIATED
I THINK THIS MOMENT WE'RE
STARTING TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
AND- A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY YOU
KNOW WHY WE TAKE IT DOWN THE
STATUES IT'S- THAT. YOU KNOW.
TWO YOU KNOW IT IS EASY TO
THING ABOUT THE STATUE OF
COURSE. THAT THEY'RE BOTH- A
COMMEMORATION OF THE MOMENT
THAT THEIR COMMEMORATING SO IN
THE CASE OF. OF THE CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS STATUE DOWN HERE. IT'S
A IT'S A COMMEMORATION OF A
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. BUT IT'S
ALSO COMMEMORATION OF THE
MOMENT WHEN THAT STATUE WAS
DECIDED TO BE PUT UP. RIGHT
IT'S A IT'S A COMMEMORATION OF
THE MOMENT OF EIGHTEEN NINETY
TWO OR WHENEVER IT WAS THAT
THAT WAS. THAT WAS PUT UP IN
AND THE VALUES AT THAT TIME AND
I THINK THAT'S- AN INTERESTING
PART OF THE DISCUSSION OVER THE
CONFEDERATE WAR STATUES RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT. ABOUT
THE CIVIL WAR HISTORY. IT'S
ALSO ABOUT THE VALUES THAT WENT
BEHIND THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DECIDED. TO CREATE MONUMENT
AVENUE IN RICHMOND AND- AND THE
KINDS OF VALUES THEY WERE
TRYING TO UPHOLD AT THE TIME.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING FOR
US TO SPEND SOME TIME THINKING
ABOUT AND CRITICIZING AND
ENGAGING IN CLEARING. SO I
CERTAINLY VERY MUCH. VERY MUCH-
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH WE'RE WE'RE NOW STARTED
TAKE SERIOUSLY HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET
EXPOSURE TO AN TO GRAPPLE WITH
THE KIND OF WORK THE KIND OF
PEDAGOGY THAT IS AT THE HEART
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM. AND I WILL SAY YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE LET'S LET'S
REMIND OURSELVES THIS ISN'T ONE
COURSE RIGHT THAT THE IDEA HERE
IS THAT IT'S A IT'S A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS YOU CAN
CHOOSE FROM A LONG LIST OF
COURSES AND THOSE COURSES COULD
INVOLVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TOPICS IN IT'S ACTUALLY TRUE
YOU CAN NOTE THAT THERE IS
THERE SOME LIMITATION TO THIS
BILL I MEAN THERE THERE'S- YOU
KNOW YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
TAKE A CLASS ON. YOUR BODY FOR
DAN BUT YOU PROP TO TAKE A
CLASS ON BETTY FRIEDAN IN CHILE.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT WOULD. BRING
TO THE INTO. NOW OF FEMINISM
AND REYES AN AFRICAN STUDIES-
SO THAT THAT WOULD BE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU WOULD START TO
SEE. IN THE COURSES THAT WOULD
BE DEVELOPED. I DO YOU KNOW. HE
TO THE EXTENT OF THE CAL STATE
IS ALREADY OBSOLETE GOING
THROUGH THEIR OWN PROCESS OF
TRYING TO COME UP WITH A
REQUIREMENT THAT IS RESPONSIVE
TO OUR WHAT THE AUTHORS LOOKING
TO DO HERE- I THINK THAT WILL
ALREADY YOU KNOW IMPROVE SOME
OF THE COSTS THAT. THE MY GOOD
FRIEND- FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WAS WAS WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THERE WERE THERE THERE
CERTAINLY WOULD BE SOME COSTS
ASSOCIATED BUT I ALWAYS I DON'T
THINK IT'S QUITE. AS HIGH AS
AND AS IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED JUST
GIVEN. THE WORK THAT'S ALREADY
UNDER WAY WITHIN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM AND I GUESS I DO WANT TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT THAT I MAKE. I HEAR A LOT
OF MY COLLEAGUES SAYING WE NEED
TO PUSH THE YOU SEE THE SENATE
CAL STATE TO ACT NOW. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WITH BILLS
RIGHT A LOT OF TIMES WE USE
BILLS AS IT OPPORTUNITY AS A
VEHICLE TO PUSH GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. AND I WILL SAY I DO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM HER INTO. IN
TERMS OF PRESSURE- YOU KNOW I
CAN IT'S NOT LOST ON ME. IT'S
NOT LOST ON ME. THAT THAT THAT
IN SOME OF OUR SISTER AND
BROTHER STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY. WE HAVE LEGISLATORS.
WHO ARE GOING IN AND ASKING
THEIR UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS TO
FIRE. PROFESSORS FOR TAKING ON
CONTROVERSIAL STANCES AND BY
THE WAY THERE OFTENTIMES THE
VERY SAME PROFESSORS WHO TEACH
IN THE CLASSES THAT WE WANT TO
SEE TAUGHT UNDER THIS
REQUIREMENT. AND THAT'S A
DANGEROUS THING I THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT I DO I DO
RESPECTFULLY PUSH BACK ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WHEN
HE SAID THAT HE DOESN'T SEE ANY
PROBLEM WITH LEGISLATOR.
WEIGHING IN AND DICTATING TERMS
IN TERMS OF EDUCATION BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT THERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE HERE.
THERE'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE HERE
AND- AND THE CAL STATE HAS
TAKEN ACTION I MEAN TO SAY THAT
THEY HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING IS
NOT TRUE. THEY THEY'VE NINETEEN
OUT OF THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES HAVE TAKEN STEPS- WITH
REGARDS TO AN ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT AND THEY'VE NOW
NOTICED. THIS REQUIREMENT. FOR
US INTO A DISCUSSION OF THE CAL
TO PASS A POLICY AT THE JULY
MEETING. SO THERE'S NO QUESTION
DRUG THE FOR THEIR TO THEY DID
THEY DID SO MANY AGENTS DO
COLLEGE OUT OF THIS MEMBER OF
BODY THAT RUN A BILL TO PUSH
OUR GOVERNMENT AGENTS THAT WAS
JUST DRAGGING ITS FEET. ADD TO
THAT YEAH WE DO HAVE THIS POWER
OF THE CAL STATE WE DON'T HAVE
IT OVER THE YOU SEE TO CLARIFY
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THE UC HAS
CONSTITUTIONAL TANAMI UNDER
ARTICLE NINE OF OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT WOULDN'T
ALLOW FOR A BILL LIKE THIS.
WITH THE GUARDS THE UC. WE
COULD DO A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. HI BUT WE COULDN'T
TELL THEM WHAT TO DO IN TERMS
OF SETTING THEIR GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. SO ARE AYE I
REALLY HOPE. I'M SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY I MADE A COMMITMENT
TO THE AUTHOR A LONG TIME AGO
AND I THINK IT'S I CAN'T HELP
IT. YOU KNOW A VASTLY EMBRACE
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
STUDYING. THE TOPICS THAT WE
SEE TO HAVE STUDIED UNDER THIS
BILL AND I WILL SAY. THAT THAT
IS AS OBSOLETE MERITORIOUS AS
OTHER SUBJECTS ARE. INCLUDING
SOME OF THE SUBJECTS THAT ARE
COVERED UNDER THE DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENT. THERE IS A- THERE
IS SOMETHING IMPORTANT THERE'S
SOMETHING SPECIAL THERE'S
SOMETHING DEEPLY. VITAL ABOUT
STUDYING ISSUES RELATED TO RACE.
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THE
CHALLENGES AND THE HISTORY THAT
EVENTS IT'S BEEN FACED BY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND I
THINK THIS MOMENT CERTAINLY
UNDERSCORES. THE INCREDIBLE
IMPORTANCE OF STANDING THOSE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS OF THOSE
GRAND GRAPPLING WITH A HISTORY.
BUT I DO I DO HOPE. AND I
REALLY HOPE AND I KNOW WE'VE
GOT A VERY THOUGHTFUL AUTHOR
HERE- IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO IT'S MY STRONG
HOPE AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
CARES ABOUT THIS TOO BECAUSE IN
THE END OF THE DAY I MEAN AS
MUCH AS WE MAY WANT TO
EXTERNALIZE THE DECISIONS OF
THIS YES YOU WE HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
DECISIONS TO MEMBERS WE-
APPROVE EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO
SITS ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AND WE SHOULD BE USING THE
RULES COMMITTEE PROCESS AND
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE HAVING A
MORE ROBUST. PROCESS FOR THE
ENTIRE BODY. WHEN IT COMES TO
THE APPROVAL AN APPOINTMENT. OF
THESE FOLKS THAT WE SEND TO RUN
THE UC SYSTEM AND SEND THE
CALIFORNIA RUN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM AND ALL THESE OTHER.
COMMISSIONS AND BOARDS AND
BODIES. MAYBE THAT PROCESS IS
TO CLOSE MADE OR NOT ASKING
ENOUGH QUESTIONS OF THESE
MEMBERS. TO ENSURE THAT WE
REALLY TRUST THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO TAKE THE KINDS OF LESSONS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY TO HEART WHEN THEY'RE
MAKING TOUGH DECISIONS. AT THE
BOARD. SO I HOPE I'VE HEARD MY
COLLEAGUES SAY THEY WANT TO
KEEP THIS DISCUSSION GOING THEY
WANT TO KEEP THIS BILL ALIVE
THEY WANT TO. THEY WANT THEY
WANT TO KEEP MOVING THIS
DISCUSSION FOR SO LET'S TAKE
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR IF THIS PASSES OUT
OF OUR LEGISLATURE HAVE THE
GOVERNOR THE CAL STATE. AND THE
AUTHOR. AND THE SPONSORS SIT
DOWN TOGETHER. AND SEE WHAT
THEY CAN WORK OUT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY OPTIMAL FOR THIS
DECISION FOR IT IS BETTER. FOR
THIS DECISION TO BE MADE BY THE
CAL STATE BOARD. AND IF THEY
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY TO COME UP
WITH A GOOD AGREEMENT THAT
MEETS THE GOALS OF THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING WITHOUT
COMMITMENT WITHOUT PROMISED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO THIS BILL.
I ALSO DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH LEGISLATION BEING USED TO
PRESSURE AGENCIES AND I THINK
THAT'S I THINK WE'VE HEARD OUR
COLLEAGUE SAYING THAT THAT'S A
LOT OF REASONS WHY THERE.
WHETHER VOTE TO PASS THIS BILL
TODAY SO I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
THIS BILL WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
I'M HOPEFUL THAT IT WILL LEAD
TO A FRUITFUL MEETING FOR
DISCUSSION THAT WILL LEAD TO
MEANINGFUL CHANGE OF THE CAL
STATE THAT WILL FINALLY
RECTIFIED AND I THINK. BRING TO
SOME. SOME CELEBRATION I
SUPPOSE OF THE MOVEMENT THAT
WAS FIRST STARTED ON THE CAL
STATE CAMPUS IN SAN FRANCISCO
IN THE SIXTIES. THAT HAS COME
SO FAR BUT THAT STILL HAS SO
MUCH FURTHER TO GO IN HELPING
TO RESHAPE OUR ACADEMY HELPING
TO. FORCE OUR SOCIETY AND OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO START ASKING
MORE CRITICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
AMERICA'S COMPLICATED
COMPLICATED HISTORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEGE THIS IS BEEN A VERY.
FASCINATING DISCUSSION AND I
HAVE- EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
ANGST ASSOCIATED WITH OUR ROLE
IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM. BUT I
AM COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THE IN
THIS INSTANCE BECAUSE IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION AGAINST THE
LEGISLATURE INTERFERING. WITH
OUR- UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE CONSTITUTION. THE SAME
IS NOT TRUE WHEN IT COMES TO
THE C. ISSUES N OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO AS THE LAWYER IN ME
AS AS SOMEONE WHO IS CONCERNED
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING THAT TO
TODAY THAT IN TWENTY YEARS
MIGHT BE USED BY SOMEONE WITH
WHOM I TOTALLY DISAGREE. TO
IMPOSE POLICIES WITH WHICH I
TOTALLY DISAGREE IS SOMETHING
THAT THE DOESN'T RISE TO THAT
LEVEL OF FOR ME TODAY AND
PERHAPS FOR OTHERS. I AM BEING
ONE OF THE MORE SENIOR MEMBERS
OF THIS HOUSE. I REMEMBER THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT LED BY.
THE GREAT DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING. ADD TO THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON WHICH IS SIMILAR IN
MANY WAYS TO SOME OF THE
MARCHES THAT WE ARE SEEING
TODAY IS THE PUBLIC IS RISING
UP. AGAIN IN OUTRAGE AND
INDIGNATION AT THE KIND OF
POLICIES THAT EXIST IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT HAVE PERPETUATED.
SLAVERY A SYSTEM THAT IS AS OLD
AS OUR REPUBLIC. AND SO IS
SOMEONE WHO LIVED THROUGH THAT
AND FAST FORWARD TO TODAY-
WE'RE STILL SEEING THIS KIND OF
BLATANT OUTRAGEOUS RACISM IN
OUR COUNTRY. BUT I'M HOPEFUL
THAT MAYBE TODAY. WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. ARE CERTAINLY ALL
OF US WHO ARE HERE NONE OF US
WERE IN A POSITION OF AUTHORITY
AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE WERE YOUNGER
AND I WAS MUCH YOUNGER THEN- ON
THE STREETS PROTESTING WITH
EVERYBODY WHO FELT THAT THIS
INJUSTICE WAS NOT ACCEPTABLE IN
THIS COUNTRY. BUT AS I LISTEN
AND LOOK AND AM CONCERNED AS A
AS A WOMAN WHO HAS LIVED THE
LIFE WHERE I'VE EXPERIENCED
INCREDIBLE GENDER BIASES MOST
WOMEN HAVE EXPERIENCED. IN THIS
SECTION ASSUME THAT IS STILL.
DEEPLYARE ENDEMIC IN OUR
SOCIETY I ASK WHAT ABOUT.
GENDER BIAS WHAT ABOUT SEXISM.
WHAT ABOUT AS WAS MENTIONED THE
WAY THE ASIAN AMERICANS WERE
TREATED AND FORCED INTO A FORM
OF SLAVERY BACK IN THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES TO DEVELOP CALIFORNIA
WHAT ABOUT WHAT ABOUT WHAT
ABOUT THERE ARE SO MANY
INSTANCES OF DISCRIMINATION
THAT HAVE EXISTED IN THIS
COUNTRY SO I ASK MYSELF WHAT IS
DISCRIMINATION WHY IS THERE
DISCRIMINATION. WE HAVE
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE OF FEAR
AND IGNORANCE. THAT IS WHAT
GENERATES HATE. YOUR AND
IGNORANCE AND I THINK IT IS
ABOUT TIME THAT WE ADDRESS THE
IGNORANCE PART OF THIS AND IF
IT MEANS THAT WE PASS FOURTEEN
SIXTY THAT IDENTIFIES FOUR
BASIC GROUPS THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED. AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT IS REALLY THE FLOOR
THAT'S THE BASICS THAT WE CAN
ADD TO THIS BECAUSE THERE IS
ENORMOUS CHANGE THEIR SEXUALITY.
OF ALL THESE ISSUES BLACK WOMEN
LUCKY NECKS. AND LETTING US.
PEOPLE OF ALL DIFFERENT RACES
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT RELIGIOUS
PERSPECTIVES AND AS A JEW I CAN
ASSURE YOU I HAVE BEEN THE
VICTIM OF ANTI SEMITISM WHICH
STILL RUNS TODAY FAIRLY
UNABASHEDLY. WE HATE BLACKS WE
HATE JEWS WE HATE FILL IN THE
BLANK. WE HAVE GOT TO ADDRESS
THE FEAR AND IGNORANCE IN OUR
COUNTRY. IT IS INEXCUSABLE THAT
IN THE NATION IT WAS BUILT BY
SLAVES AND BUILD BY WOMEN AND
BUILT BY PEOPLE OF COLOR. THERE
WE SHOULD STILL HAVE A COUNTRY
THAT TRIES AT EVERY POSSIBLE
CHANCE TO PUT THOSE PEOPLE
THERE. AND SO I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT IS MY HOPE
THAT AS THE- CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY- OUR DISCUSSION IS
HOW TO BEST UNDERMINE THE FEAR
AND THE HATRED AND THE
IGNORANCE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
EDUCATION IS SUPPOSED TO DO. IT
IS SUPPOSED TO EDUCATE AND
REMOVE IGNORANCE SO THAT PEOPLE
MAKE DECISIONS AND IS MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
MENTIONED THE PURPOSE OF
EDUCATION IS TO TEACH PEOPLE TO
THINK CRITICALLY. GIVE PEOPLE
THE AXE GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
OTHERS AND WHAT WILL WE FIND
THAT WE ARE ALL HUMAN BEINGS.
GUARD LIST OF OURS REGARDLESS
OF OUR OF OUR RACIAL
COMPOSITION REGARDLESS OF
MARBLE RELIGIOUS BELIEFS WE ARE
ALL HUMAN BEINGS. AND THAT IS
REALLY THE PROMISE OF THIS
COUNTRY IT IS A PROMISE THAT
THIS BILL TRIES TO START OVER
AGAIN. LET'S HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE IN
THIS COUNTRY HISTORY SOMETHING
WE DON'T REALLY GIVE A WHOLE
LOT OF CONSIDERATION TO
ANYMORE. BUT I THINK HISTORY IS
ONE OF THE MOST INVALUABLE
THINGS WE CAN DO BECAUSE THE
TIMES MAY CHANGE BUT HUMAN
NATURE WILL NEVER CHANGE. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE
THOSE EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES
THAT THIS MEASURE WILL AGAIN
REYES AND MAKE PART OF A YOUNG
PERSON'S EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND IT IS
MY HOPE AS WELL. THAT THE A CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WILL
COME UP WITH THE BEST PLAN AND
THAT THIS BILL WILL HAVE BEEN
AN INCENTIVE BUT NOT THE END OF
THIS DISCUSSION. AND SO THAT
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL. THE MEN.
ARE IN AND OTHERS WHO HAVE AND
SHE EXT THIS KIND OF
DISCRIMINATION BUT ONBEHALF OF
THOSE GROUPS THAT ARE NOW
FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE THAT THAT
HAD THAT HAS BEEN THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE. IT IS FOR ALL OF US IN
THE FACT THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO RAISE THE CONSCIOUSNESS OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND ADDRESS
THOSE INHERENT OF FEELINGS OF
PREJUDICE AND DISCRIMINATION
AND OVERCOME THEM. THERE CAN BE
I THINK NO GREATER. EFFORT AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR- FOR HER COURAGE I
IN RAISING THIS ISSUE AND HOPE
THAT THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IS LISTENING CAREFULLY
TO THIS DEBATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR JACKSON CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MEMBERS YOU KNOW WHEN
I WAS FOUR YEARS OLD THE KING
AND THE QUEEN OF THE GYPSIES OF
CALIFORNIA MOVE NEXT DOOR MY
GRANDPARENTS. THOSE WERE THE
FONDEST MEMORIES OF MY
CHILDHOOD. AND WE'RE STILL
FRIENDS TO THIS DAY FIFTY TWO
YEARS LATER. IT WAS A RICH
EXPERIENCE FOR ME- YET WHEN I
WAS YOUNGER AND BY THE TIME I
WAS IN SECOND GRADE MY PARENTS
HAD DIVORCED AND WE WERE
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME AT MY
GRANDPARENTS HOUSE AND WE WERE
ALWAYS GOING OVER THE GYPSIES
HOUSE. BECAUSE THERE I HAD
THREE MOMS THAT PAID ATTENTION
TO ME THERE WERE THREE
GENERATIONS IN THE FAMILY. AND
I HAD MY FRIENDS JANEANE LARA
DOROTHY. AND MANY OTHERS THAT
WERE AT THE HOME ALL THE TIME.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT RACISM
WAS WHEN I WAS IN FIRST AND
SECOND GRADE. BUT IN MEMORY
THAT I STILL HOLD ALL THESE
YEARS LATER WAS BEING OUT WITH
MY GYPSY FRIENDS WHO ARE PROUD
TO CALL THEMSELVES GYPSIES BY
THE WAY. AND SOME WOMEN LOOKING
OVER TO US. AND I REMEMBER
FEELING HURT AND I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
BUT DINA WHO WAS WITH US SHE
SAID. THE LADY SAID WERE MIL
LOLLY. WERE DIRTY AND THEIR
LANGUAGE MALALA EIGHT THIRTY I
REMEMBER THAT ALL THESE YEARS
LATER WE WEREN'T DIRTY WE WERE
DRESSED UP WE'RE WEARING
DRESSES. WHAT SHE MET WITH
SOMETHING ELSE AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL LATER THAT I UNDERSTOOD
WHAT THAT WAS BUT I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER IT. AND TO THIS DAY
WHEN I TALK ABOUT MY FRIENDS
WHO WERE GYPSIES I STILL HEAR
THINGS THAT ARE DEROGATORY
ABOUT THEM AND IT HURTS BECAUSE
I LOVE THEM DEARLY LIKE MY OWN
FAMILY TO THIS DAY. I TOOK A
WOMEN OF COLOR CLASSES
SACRAMENTO STATE AND THERE'S SO
MUCH THAT I DON'T REMEMBER THAT
I LEARNED IN COLLEGE. BUT THOSE
WERE LIFETIME LESSONS THAT I
LEARNED THAT I TOOK WITH ME. I
AM PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
GALGIANI SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THIS
CONVERSATION- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE JUST A
MOMENT TO REFLECT THE TIMES
THAT WERE IN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT EVERY FAMILIES ARE HAVING
IN LIVING ROOMS ACROSS OUR
NATION AND- I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW
THAT IT'S BEEN- A MISSION FOR
HER AND SEVENTEEN THAT SHE'S
WORKED DILIGENTLY ON. I DON'T
WANT TO THINK DOCTOR WEBER IT'S
NOT AN EASY TOPIC TO EMBARK ON-
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FOR ARE YOU
YOUR COMMENTS I THINK ALL OF
YOU HAVE VALID POINTS IN ALL OF
YOU ARE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN AND I JUST
WANT TO ADD MY VOICE AS A
TEACHER- I REMEMBER T.
EIGHTEEN. OP SOCIAL STUDIES
NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS AND I THINK
THAT WAS ONE OF MY BIGGEST
FRUSTRATIONS AS I YOU KNOW LOOK
THROUGH THE CURRICULUM IS
FINDING MYSELF CONSTANTLY
TAKING OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM
OUTSIDE THE- GIVING CURRICULUM
TO FIND THE REAL HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I THINK
THAT- WE FIND OURSELVES NOT
RESPECTING OUR STUDENTS. BY
TRYING TO GIVE THEM INFORMATION
NOTS WATERED DOWN AND DOESN'T
REALLY THE FLAT THE TRUE
HISTORY OF THIS STATE AND THIS
COUNTRY AND- AND BECAUSE OF
THOSE STRUGGLES I ALWAYS FIND
MYSELF REACHING OUT TO THOSE
EVERY NEW- SOME OF THE TRIBES
ENGAGING IN CONVERSATION SO I
REALLY WANTED TO UNDERSTAND AND
I REALLY WANT MY STUDENTS TO
HAVE. THE TRUE INFORMATION SO
THEN THEY CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED HERE I THINK THAT
IF WE GIVE THEM HISTORY AND
REALLY HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
MISTAKES HE MADE CAN ONLY MAKE
THEM STRONGER AND BETTER FOR IT
AND HOPEFULLY THEY STILL REPEAT
SOME OF THE MISTAKES TAT WE'VE
MADE BECAUSE I THINK EVERY
GENERATION WE GROW LITTLE BY
LITTLE WE GIRL AND I HOPE THAT-
WE HAVEN'T STOPPED GROWING AND
THIS IS JUST ONCE AT. FORWARD
AND GROOMING A NECK GEN. THAT
GOING TO BE. UNDERSTANDING MORE
ABOUT THAT A- LITTLE BIT MORE
AWARE OF THEIR SURROUNDINGS AND
REALLY I THINK THIS BOILS DOWN
TO UNDERSTANDING. UNDERSTANDING
OTHER PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEIR
STRUGGLES AND I THINK WE CAN
ONLY BE A BETTER STATE FOR IT
AND SO I CALLED PARTY. AT MY
VOICE TO THOSE THAT SUPPORTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I COULD JUST
CAST A VOTE HERE- QUIETLY IN
SIR TO PROCEED. VERY RICH IN
FULL DEBATE BUT I CAN'T HELP
BUT ADD MY VOICE TO THE
CONVERSATION. I DON'T WANT TO
BE A RELUCTANT HI VOTE. I DON'T
WANT TO BE A SHEEPISH AYE VOTES
I DON'T WANT TO FEEL. OR YOU
ALL THE FEEL THAT THIS VOTE IS
BEING CAST JUST BECAUSE OF THIS
MOMENT BECAUSE- THERE'S SO MUCH
MOMENTUM HERE AND JUST HAS TO
BE DONE. THERE'S A MOMENT TO BE
PROUD OF A VOTE LIKE THIS. THE
MOMENT TO BE PROUD TO STAND UP
AND SAY THE ISSUE OF RACE
SPECIFICALLY. NEEDS TO BE
TALKED ABOUT. THIS IS A MOMENT
WHERE IT'S VERY EASY. TO LOOK
AT THE HOLES AND SAY WHO'S
MISSING. AND I HAVE THAT SAME.
INSTINCT POP UP IN MYSELF. EVEN
GOING THROUGH WHAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH IN LOS ANGELES OVER THE
PAST FEW WEEKS. WHEN YOU SEE A
SYNAGOGUE GET DESECRATED. OR
ANTI SEMITIC HATRED RISE ONLINE
YOU SAY THIS IS THE MEMORIA TO
STAND UP AND SAY NO TO ANTI
SEMITISM AND WHERE IS WHERE IS
THAT EXPERIENCE IN THIS BILL
AND WHERE IS THIS IN OUR
DIALOGUE. THIS IS SINGULARLY A
MOMENT RIGHT NOW. THAT IS ABOUT
BEING A PERSON OF COLOR A
WALKING AROUND IN A BLACK BODY
IN THIS COUNTRY BEING DIFFERENT
THEY'RE WALKING AROUND IN A
WHITE BODY. THAT EVEN THOUGH IN
FIFTY YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS FIVE
YEARS OLD I WENT TO THE SAME
KINDERGARTEN CLASS THAT. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WENT
TO WE BOTH WERE IN THE SAME
SCHOOL PLAY I PLAYED MARTIN
LUTHER KING AT FIVE YEARS OLD.
SHE HELPED BUILD THE VOTING
BOOTH IN THAT SAME- BIT OF
CHILD PETER WE DID. AND YET IN
MY MIND AT THE TIME I DIDN'T
REALIZE WILL. YEAH I CAN BE
JUST LIKE MARTIN LUTHER KING
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT AT THE
TIME. WHITE KID GROWING UP.
NICE PART LA. NOT REALIZING
THAT. THERE'S SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT. AND
FUNDAMENTALLY HARDER ABOUT
WALKING DOWN THE STREET. RIDING
A BICYCLE GOING TO GET YOUR
LUNCH ALL THOSE SMALL MOMENTS
THAT YOU DON'T NOTICE IN YOUR
LIFE. IF WE CAN'T TALK
SINGULARLY ABOUT RACE IN THIS
MOMENT. AND FORCE THAT. THAT
GREAT ON KNOWING THAT JAMES
BALDWIN TALKED ABOUT NOT IN NOT
EVEN IN IGNORANCE BUT A
CONSCIOUS ON KNOWING. AN ACTUAL
INTENTIONAL AVOIDANCE OF THE
ISSUE- MISEDUCATION NOT A LACK
OF EDUCATION A MISS EDUCATION.
WE PRESENT A VERSION OF HISTORY
IN THIS CAPITAL WHEN PEOPLE
WALK IN. IN OUR CLASSROOMS IN
OUR CURRICULUM AND WE'VE WAITED
IN THE CURRICULUM BEFORE. WE
TELL YOUNG PEOPLE LEARN ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT IN THERE K.
TWELVE EDUCATION. WE URGE THEM
TO LEARN ABOUT. GENOCIDES IN
WARS. I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THAT POSTURE AND THAT THEIR
RETICENCE TO REACH TOO DEEPLY
OF OUR POLITICS BUT IF WE ARE
NOT EDUCATING YOUNG PEOPLE
ABOUT RACE. AND FORCING THAT
COLLISION. AND FORCING KIDS OUT
OF THEIR SHELL WE ARE MISS
EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN. IT'S
NOT THAT THE- THEY NOW HAVE A
SUPER CHARGED EDUCATION THEY'RE
JUST THEY'RE JUST GONNA BE
GRADUATE WITHOUT THAT BLIND
SPOT. WE'RE DOCUMENT THREE
UNITS HERE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A CLASS. I UNDERSTAND THE
PROCEDURAL CONCERNS.
INTERVENING INTO EXISTING
AGENCIES WORK BUT. YOU KNOW
THERE THERE IS A RISK AT THIS
MOMENT THE WORD ETHNIC GOES
BACK TO THE WORD ETHNOS A COMES
FROM GREEK ETYMOLOGY. THE WORD
THEY USED FOR OTHER. ETHNOS WAS
ALSO MENTIONED IN THE FIRST
GREEK TRANSLATION OF THE HEBREW
BIBLE. THE TALK ABOUT NON JEWS
OTHERS GOYIM. BUT THAT WORD
ETHNOS. NOW PIERS TODAY AS
ETHNIC WHAT IS OTHER. THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN OTHERS THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY. AND CERTAINLY NOW THE
OTHER. AND THE WAY WE TREATED
IS PEOPLE BY COLOR THEIR SKIN.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN OTHERS
BECAUSE OF THEIR RELIGION.
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER.
BECAUSE THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND THE RISK IN THIS
MOMENT IS CASTING. THAT BERRIER
OF OTHERNESS WHEN WE ALL HAVE
TO FIND SOME BRIDGES BETWEEN.
OUR TRIBES. IF YOU GO BACK TO
THE CURRENT BIBLE VERSES IN
THIS WEEK EVEN THE DIVISION OF
ALL THE TRIBES EVEN AMONGST
JEWS THERE WERE TWELVE TRIBES
AND THEY ALL WANTED TO WAR
AMONGST EACH OTHER AND FIND
THEIR OWN ETHNIC LINES THAT
DIVIDE THEMSELVES. BUT WHEN WE
ARE MURMURING AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER WE BECOME A TOWER OF
BABEL. WE GET NOTHING DONE.
LET'S BE CLEAR IN OUR VOICE
TODAY. I'LL BE CLEAR THIS
MOMENT IS ABOUT A CONVERSATION.
ABOUT ETHNICITY BUT AS THE BILL
MENTIONS SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
RACIALIZED MINORITIES AND WHAT
IT IS TO GO THROUGH LIFE THAT
WAY. I PROBABLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AND I HOPE WE CAN MOVE
THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION FORD IS
LEGISLATURE IN A WAY THAT.
REALLY RECTIFY IS OUR TROOPS IN
HISTORY. BUT THROUGH THAT TRUTH
SOME KIND OF RECONCILIATION.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN CENTER
CHIANG. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THIS IS THIS IS A
TOUGH VOTE FOR ME I KEEP GOING
BACK AND FORTH AND- I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM. AROUND
A AND ALSO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA. YOU KNOW WE DO
NEED TO SET A HIGH BAR FOR
IMPOSING REQUIREMENTS ON THE
CSU AND IT WOULD BE BETTER FOR
THE CSU TO DO IT ON THEIR OWN.
BUT I FEEL LIKE THIS MOMENT.
CALLS FOR THAT CHANGE. I KEEP
GOING BACK AND FORTH BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT MY WHOLE
ENTIRE LIFE ALMOST WEEKLY. I AM
SUBJECT TO SOME OF RACISM SOME
TYPE OF RACISM AND AS THE ONLY
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN IN THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW. I FEEL
LIKE I NEED TO SPEAK UP. AND
YOU KNOW IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE I
KEEP GOING BACK TO THIS ONE
TIME I LOVE KNOCKING ON DOORS I
LOVE TALKING TO PEOPLE AND I'M
NOT GOING ON THIS ONE DOOR AND
THIS WOMAN OPENED THE DOOR AND
SHE SAID I WILL NEVER VOTE FOR
AN ORIENTAL. AND I SAID BUT WHY
SO I SPENT FORTY FIVE MINUTES
AT HER DOOR. AND EIGHTY IT WAS
CLEAR TO ME THAT. IT WAS MORE
OF. IGNORANCE IT WASN'T SO MUCH
HATRED BUT THERE WAS A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING. THAT HEY WE ARE
ALL THE SAME. YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALL HERE. TRYING TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY TRYING TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY. AND AFTER THAT FORTY
FIVE MINUTES I WON HER OVER AND
SHE ENDED UP ASKING ME HOW MY
HOUSE AND I WILL FOR THE REST
OF THE BILL. BUT HERE BUT
THAT'S THE THING IS IT'S NOT SO
MUCH HATRED BUT WE SHOULD STOP
IT. WE SHOULD NIP THAT RIGHT AT
THE BLOOD. TO KILL. IGNORANCE
BECAUSE IN IGNORANCE BECOMES.
HATRED YOU KNOW IT CAN BECOME
HATRED. AND AGAIN LIKE LIKE
LIKE I SAID I'M SITTING HERE
GOING BACK AND FORTH. BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE TO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE TO SUPPORT BECAUSE
IF WE CAN OF- KILL HATRED BY
JUST INFORMING AND EDUCATING
YOU KNOW OUR STUDENTS TO THINK
CRITICALLY TO THINK IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. TO SEEK MORE
UNDERSTANDING I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY. THANK
YOU CENTER CHIANG SEEING NO
OTHER MIKE SUB MISTER BRADFORD
WOULD YOU CARE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND I
WANNA THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THIS. HEARTFELT AND HEALTHY
DEBATE ON ISSUE REALLY NOT OF
EDUCATION AGAIN A ISSUE OF.
RACE IN AMERICA- ISSUE OF THE
MIS EDUCATION OF AMERICANS-
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE WE'VE
HEARD THAT ECHOED SO MANY TIMES
FROM SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES.
BECAUSE OF THE- MISS EDUCATION
THERE WAS A BOOK THE MIS
EDUCATION OF THE NEGRO. BECAUSE
FOR FOUR HUNDRED YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN LIED TO ABOUT WHAT THIS
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY IS
REALLY ABOUT. BEEN THE
MISEDUCATION OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF NOT ONLY THE
NEGRO BUT NATIVE AMERICANS OF
ASIANS AS WE HEARD OF OUR
LATINO BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
IT'S BEEN WHITEWASHED IN OUR
HISTORY BOOKS AT OUR
UNIVERSITIES BUT HERE'S A
OPPORTUNITY TODAY MEMBERS TO
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT. AND
IT'S NOT TO EXCLUDE ANY OTHER
GROUP BUT TO INCLUDE THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND FOR SO
LONG. IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
AGAIN RIGHT THE WRONGS WERE
COME INTO THIS WORLD WITH ONLY
TWO FEARS THE FEAR FALLING THE
FEAR LAW WHILE LOUD NOISES
EVERYTHING ELSE IS TAUGHT. SO
WE HATE ONE ANOTHER IT'S TAUGHT
IN OUR UNIVERSITIES IS THOUGHT
AND I'LL IMAGES GOES IT'S
TAUGHT IN OUR HOMES. AND.
WHAT'S OFTEN STATED A PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT KNOW THEIR HISTORY
ARE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW OUR
HISTORY WE HAVE ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES SAY WHY NOW WELL
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING SAYS
THE TIME IS ALWAYS RIGHT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND IF NOT NOW
THEN WHEN HE ALSO SPOKE OF THE
URGENCY OF NOW AND URGENCY IT
NOW HAS BEEN CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED OVER THE LAST
THREE WEEKS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD THAT WE NEED A
SYSTEMIC CHANGE WHEN IT COMES
TO TALKING ABOUT. OUR GREAT
DIVERSITY BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
OUR ETHNIC DIFFERENCES HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY AND HERE'S
OPPORTUNITY BY A FOURTEEN
INDIVIDUALS TO LEARN. I GREW UP
IN A HOSTILE WORK. BOTH MY
PARENTS WERE COLLEGE EDUCATED
HAVING REPORT. MY FATHER OWNED
HIS OWN BUSINESS MY MOTHER WAS
A NURSE ALL MY FAMILY. MY
MOTHER'S SISTERS ALL COLLEGE
EDUCATED OUR PROFESSORS ARE
PRESENT PRINTABLE THAT SCHOOLS.
N. B. INSTILLED IN ME THE
IMPORTANCE OF NóI MY HISTORY.
AND I WENT TO COLLEGE AS A
FRESHMAN AT SAN DIEGO STATE TO.
AT THE BIOLOGY MAJOR WITH EVERY
INTENTION OF BEING A DOCTOR NOT
A POLITICIAN NOT A SENATOR BUT
A DOCTOR. AND IT WAS A FRESHMAN
CLASS THAT I TOOK. TAUGHT BY A
PROFESSOR DR SHIRLEY WEBER.
AFTER AN AMERICAN STUDIES
COURTS. AND I DROPPED IT THREE
WEEKS INTO IT BECAUSE I HAD A
BETTER CHANCE OF PASSING
MICROBIOLOGY THAT AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES BECAUSE I
REALIZED HOW ILL EQUIPPED
EDUCATED I WAS TO KNOW ABOUT MY
OWN HISTORY AND ABOUT MY OLD
CULTURE AND AS OFTEN SAY HAD I
STAYED IN THAT CLASS I MIGHT
HAVE BEEN SOMEBODY. BUT I'M
HERE TODAY TO SAY IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT WE MOVE FOR
WITH THIS MEASURE. IT'S NOT
ABOUT COST BECAUSE THE COST
ABOUT DIGNITY IS FAR GREATER
THAN THE COST OF. WHAT DOES
PROGRAMS GONNA ACOSTA
UNIVERSITIES WE HAVE PLENTY
MONEY TO FUND THOSE THINGS THAT
WE FEEL WARM PART. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO AGAIN.
EDUCATE NOT ONLY ARE
CALIFORNIANS I STARTED WITH. H.
B. C. USE I AGAIN I CHALLENGE
ANY OF YOU TO HAVE A DEBATE ON
AMERICAN HISTORY WITH SOMEONE
WHO WENT TO H. B. C. USE
PROBLEMS THEY'RE FAR MORE
PREPARED BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
HISTORY. I WENT TO A-
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHERE I WAS
PROBABLY ONE OF FIFTY BLACK
KIDS AT AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
THERE WAS ONE AFTER AMERICAN
TEACHERS IN THAT SCHOOL. HER
NAME WAS JACQUELINE HALLS. IN A
WOMAN CHANGE MY LIFE. BUT SHE
GRADUATED AT SPELMAN COLLEGE
SHE BABY SAT MARTIN LUTHER KING
AND SHE TAUGHT ME A AND ALL MY
OTHER DIVERSE CLASSMATES BUT
THE HISTORY OF NOT ONLY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT BUT THE
RICH CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO THIS COUNTRY. AND
I THANK HER FOR THAT. AND I
HAD- IN THE FOURTH GRADE. IN A
PROGRESS TO THE FIFTH GRADE.
LOOKED AROUND I HAVE MISSILES
AGAIN IN THE FIFTH GRADE WANT
TO THE SIX GRADE HIGHER MISS
LAWS IN THE SIXTH GRADE I.
HATED BUT I LOVED IT WHEN I
LOOK BACK AT IT WAS THE BEST
THING TO THEIR YEAR I MOVED UP
SO DID SHE- AND I HAD THREE
YEARS OF HER IMPACT IN MY LIFE
ND SO MANY OF MY OTHER.
CLASSMATES ON THE RICH HISTORY
OF OUR CONTRIBUTIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I PROBABLY WOULD
NAY AT IT ANY OTHER WAY. AND
AGAIN MY MOTHER WENT TO H. B.
C. USE COLLEGE. AND SHE
INSTILLED AS WELL AS MY FALL IN
IMPORTS OF NO ONE OUR HISTORY
BUT AGAIN. OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
DOES NOT PREPARE US TO KNOW THE
REAL TRUTH THE REAL HISTORY.
THIS COURSE WILL ALLOW. A LEASE
ENTREE A LITTLE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR BRADFORD CLEAR CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA OR AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. WELL BY
FORGES. NO BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM
I CHIANG I DOLLY. DODD I THERE
ARE SO. I GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL I HUESO HI TANTO I JACKSON
I JONES. NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO HI
ROSS. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER NINE I WHAT
CASKEY I WIENER I WILK HI THE
CLERK CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES TALLY. GLAZER GROWTH NO
MORE LOCK. NIELSEN. PRICE
THIRTY KNOWS FIVE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
GONZALEZ. OCEANS AND
RESOLUTIONS I REQUEST THAT FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE S. R. EIGHTY
THREE BE MOVED TO THE ENOUGH TO
FILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE TO SEVENTY NINE. NOW WOULD
BE THE TIME OF A MEMBER WANTED
ONE OF THOSE ITEMS FULL TO ASK
FOR THAT. SEEING SAYING- NO
MIKE'S UP THE- CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. 1-781-616-9170 AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY SIX. RIGHT CLARK A
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES BY
BELL HI GORGEOUS I BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO. HI CHIANG I DALLY I
DODD. I THERE ARE SO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG HI HILL. HI
I HUESO AYE- TADO I JACKSON.I
JONES I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ. I MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK I MORRELL I NIELSEN.
I HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI STERN I AM
VERY I WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
I WILL HI. PRICE FORTY NO ZERO
SPECIAL CASSETTE CALENDAR
ADOPTED. SEEING NO MIKE'S UP NO
OTHER BUSINESS IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES I WILL ASK FOR THE
COURTESY OF JUST A MOMENT TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS. WHAT
AN INCREDIBLY POWERFUL WEEK
THIS HAS BEEN FOR OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION. WE MET ARE DEADLINE
PASSED A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
THAT IS FAITHFUL TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PRIORITIES
CLOSES THE FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR GAP. AND PROTECTS CORE
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THIS WOULD BE AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT WORTHY OF PRAISE
IN ANY YEAR. BUT IS THAT MUCH
MORE AMAZING WHEN VIEWED
THROUGH THE LENS OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT AND CHALLENGES THAT
HAVE FOLLOWED. BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS WITH GOVERNOR
NEWSOME ARE PROGRESSING. AND WE
ARE WORKING ON FINE TUNING OUR
PROPOSAL TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL WHO LIVE HERE. AND WHILE
WE WORK ON BUDGETS POLICY AND
LEGISLATION THE SUPREME COURT
WAS WORKING TO PROTECT
SAFEGUARDS FOR THE LGBT Q.
WORKERS AND FOR IMMIGRANTS. ON
MONDAY WE WOKE TO THE NEWS THAT
THE JUSTICES HAD DECIDED THAT
TITLE SEVEN OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT BARRING SEX DISCRIMINATION
IN THE WORKPLACE ALSO PROTECTS
THE LGBT Q. WORKERS. FROM BEING
FIRED ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY. ONE OF THE FIRST LAWS
I WROTE AS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE DEFINITION
OF GENDER IN CERTAIN ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS. SO THAT IS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LGBT Q. WORKERS. NOW THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING AFFIRMS
THAT PROTECTION THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION. WHAT A WELCOME WHEN TO
CELEBRATE DURING PRIDE MONTH.
THAT SAME DAY THE COURT
REJECTED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CHALLENGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
VALUES ACT WHICH PREVENTS STATE
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
SHARING IMMIGRANTS PERSONAL
INFORMATION. WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES AND
TRANSFERRING THEM TO
IMMIGRATION CUSTODY. WHEN
IMMIGRANTS ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK
UP IN REPORT CRIMES NONE OF US
ARE SAFE. SB FIFTY FOUR
AUTHORED BY MY PREDECESSOR AND
OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE KEVIN DE
LEON WAS AND CONTINUES TO BE
CRITICAL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
OUR STATE. AND TODAY WE CAN
CELEBRATE ANOTHER VICTORY THE
SUPREME COURT'S UPHOLDING OF
THE DEFERRED ACTION FOR
CHILDHOOD ARRIVALS OR DACA
PROGRAM. THE DECISION IS A
DESERVED TO WIN BOTH FOR
DREAMERS OUR STATE AND THE
ENTIRE NATION. WE'VE BEEN
ESTIMATED HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND DACA RECIPIENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND NOW THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO GO TO SCHOOL
AND WORK WITHOUT FEAR OF
DEPORTATION. THIS WEEK IS A WIN
FOR EQUALITY AND IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND TRULY FEELS LIKE
JUSTICE AND THE RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE HAVE PREVAILED. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO. AND JUST A MINUTE
AGO. THE SENATOR FROM GUARDINO
SUCCESSFULLY MOVED AB. FOURTEEN
SIXTY MAKING CALIFORNIA THE
FIRST IN THE NATION TO REQUIRE
ETHNIC STUDIES AS A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. COLLEAGUES I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN WITH THESE
VICTORIES TOP OF MIND CAN CARRY
THAT SPIRIT OF COMMITMENT AND
COURAGE THAT HELP THEM SUCCEED.
INTO OUR WORK IN THE COMING
WEEKS WE WILL NEED IT BUT I
KNOW WE ARE UP FOR THE
CHALLENGE. COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE WILL ADJOURN UNTIL
MONDAY. JUNE TWENTY SECOND AT
ONE PM THANK YOU. MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT ONE PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.